two and i was 11. so it's been a while
is that something
you thought you'd ever see again
1992 was a good year that was my second
year of law school
so now that makes me feel really old but
i i did
think that i was treated and i'm so glad
it's during this
election um
this is such an important year obviously
because of the opportunity we have to
elect two senators
an opportunity to send our electoral
votes
for joe biden but on top of that as you
know we lost three icons in our state
this year dr
c.t vivian dr joseph lowry and
congressman john lewis and so it's so
fitting
that in the spirit of all that they've
represented that we saw this
diverse coalition of folk across georgia
show
up and vote and it has made a difference
and i'm so proud of our state
it does have that deep sense of history
and certainly
the three icons that you named their
legacy i think is in the minds of
of many voters certainly the passing of
congressman john lewis was in the mind
of many voters in georgia the georgia
secretary of state said
a recount is almost inevitable due to
the
the small lead that biden now has do you
anticipate
any of that changing the outcome of the
race ultimately
no i don't um we we may see just a
slight change which is not uncommon when
you have a recount we even see recounts
where sometimes the winners get more
votes you can't
assume that a recount will favor the
person
who's on the losing end but i think that
a recount will be important if that
helps
people feel more confident about the
integrity of this election
and allows us to move on with this
transition
and to begin to heal as a nation that's
why we
have elected joe biden president and it
is uh it's long overdue
and i i am looking forward to his
presidency
and all that the integrity that he will
bring back to the white house
you mentioned the late congressman john
lewis
his district includes clayton county
where
biden is now finally being
put ahead in the vote count as a result
of the count coming from clayton county
he represented that county for more than
30 years how do you think his legacy
as you mentioned influenced voters you
know do you think that was in the back
of their minds as they went
or mailed in their ballots sure and and
the metro area was so
important john lewis also represented
parts of fulton county
and dekalb county both all three
counties were
are obviously very important in the
outcome of this election
but you remember the parting words that
congressman lewis left us
in his essay where he told us that our
vote is our most powerful weapon
and if we don't exercise our right to
vote then we could lose it
and there were posters all over atlanta
reminding us
that we saw the nba players with it on
their jerseys and i know that it was in
the hearts of people and even when i saw
people standing in these long lines for
hours there was such
dignity and just such um a resolve
and confidence and and there's so many
words that i could use but you could
feel the energy and i know that has
everything to do with what john lewis
left with us
that almost gives me chills thinking
about voters
standing there and just having the
resolve to stay there until they
were able to cast their ballots you know
you don't want people to have to stand
on lines but the fact that they are
willing to do so
um is so incredibly powerful
particularly when it comes to
african americans in this country um you
know
we're setting up for a couple of runoffs
uh
georgia is still uh very much a
battleground state
in in terms of the senate seats as well
and it looks like we're set up for a
runoff
the outcome of those two races could
single-handedly determine
uh which party controls the chamber how
do you think democrats will
fare in the runoff on january
5th well i reminded people last week of
my race for mayor just three years ago
almost a hundred 000 votes cast 832
votes in the runoff made the difference
that allowed me to be mayor of atlanta
so people have to recognize that it's
not over
and our vote is even more important
because
obviously uh joe biden and senator or
vice president um
kamala harris as it will be will need
the support of the senate so
people in so many ways have to be
educated
but they have to know that this
election means so much to this country
and i truly believe
that people will be energized by the
attention that's been given to
georgia and i'm confident that they're
going to show back up
but we can't take it for granted we
still got to put in the work
in terms of just the history that's
happening in this moment it's so
shocking to me in some ways that
the fact that america is about to have
maybe
a vice president who is a woman we've
never had that uh she's also a black and
south asian
woman we've never had a woman at all so
the fact that it's a woman of color
uh you know who could potentially be the
vice president seems like a big deal
in your view just reflect on what it
means to you as a black woman
uh you as somebody in a position of
leadership to see
kamala harris rise uh potentially to
become
the first woman vice president of the
united states of america
it gives me so much pride and every
conversation i have with joe biden he
talked about
wanting his ticket and his
administration
to reflect the diversity of america and
to represent who we are
and here we have an hvcu graduate
a woman a very accomplished woman
um and it is it's great to
for me to see it happen but i'm also
happy that my mother gets to see it
and my daughter gets to see it because
this is
so much that so many generations have
hoped for
and then it's a great example for our
children on what's possible so
uh 2020 we can say a lot
about 2020 but there are many silver
linings and
and this will be one of them
mayor keisha lance bottoms thank you so
much for being here
coming up i'll talk to congresswoman
mary gay scanlon
of the all-important state of
pennsylvania and as we go to break
votes are still being counted in the
remaining battleground states
and it might be a few more days before
we have a final count
we know everyone wants to know who won
but please
be patient so you said
the thirty one thousand was the total
for this morning it won't be your thirty
thousand it's not thirty one thousand
i'm sorry
thirty can you so let's just be clear
here thirty thousand four oh three was
in
thirty thousand four oh three this
afternoon before four p.m how many do
you expect because we're starting to
dump two reports a day i can't
accurately give you that number
when it comes to las vegas you can
usually get what you want when you want
it
but when it comes to this election we
all just have to be really patient
let's take a look at the count in nevada
right now joe biden is holding on to a
slim lead but nbc news still has
the race too close to call in clark
county home to las vegas
they have more than 60 thousand mail-in
ballots to count
which they expect to finish by sunday
the trump campaign has been making
baseless claims about voter fraud in
nevada
we're still waiting on any evidence to
back it up
a lawsuit was expected but nothing has
been filed yet
also out west the tight race in arizona
biden
still holds a slim lead there as well
but nbc says that race is also too close
to call
trump supporters have been outside the
maricopa county elections office the
last few nights ironically
demanding that all the votes be counted
and yes
that is alex jones leading the crowd
massless
in phoenix last night now let's be clear
if joe biden wins the state of
pennsylvania
then he wouldn't need nevada arizona or
georgia
to reach 270 electoral votes but they
would matter when it comes to making a
statement
and running up the score joining us now
political reporter for the washington
post and host of the new podcast
the next four years eugene scott
democratic strategist aisha mills and
white house reporter for reuters jeff
mason jeff i want to start with you
what are you hearing from inside your
white house
bubble about the president's posture
right now we've heard a lot about
you know his mood swings and how he's
feeling but as joe biden inches closer
to 270
what's the state of mind of the
president right now
well the i can't speak to his state of
mind but i can speak to what
people around him are saying and what
he's been doing which is
basically adopting a a fighting posture
i think that he has shown with his
statement today
that he with the it was a written
statement that he wants to
fight until all legal challenges have
been exhausted
and certainly until all of the votes
have been counted he of course would use
the term legal votes
but in general the sources i spoke to
today just emphasized that they want
these counts to be finished
so i think it's it's a fighting posture
but i would add to that
uh that there is also certainly a sense
among many people around him
that his chances are dwindling because
they're able to look and see the numbers
that we are looking at and that the
biden campaign is looking at
and have a realistic view that that his
options have narrowed but given that
even with that reality setting in uh
he's not ready to concede
that's that's a wow eugene for people
watching at home
right now wondering why we're not
calling joe biden the president-elect
explain to the folks at home what we're
waiting for
well we're waiting for the vote to
continue there was some confusion
earlier this week about whether or not
arizona could be called for biden or not
i believe fox caught it and
had to walk it back and so there's some
certainty that people feel like uh
you know we should have and i say people
i mean news organizations
um to before actually calling all things
um there is also likely going to be a
recount in the state of georgia because
it is so close
um and so they're they're what people
want to be careful secretaries of states
want to be careful
campaign parties want to be careful on
both sides uh to not
find themselves in a situation um that
is
that resembles the 2000 election when uh
news organizations called the race for
al gore and then had to walk it back and
it just created so much
confusion and media distrust that um it
just left a stain on the whole process
of declaring a winner
i remember that well i should take us uh
to 30
000 feet like let's look big picture we
are witnessing history
on so many different levels joe biden
earned more votes than any candidate
ever to run for president
kamala harris on the cusp of becoming
the first woman
in the history of the united states to
be vice president
put this all into historical perspective
for us
you know zelena i've really been
struggling with this all week because it
is history in the making number one we
as americans should just be proud of
ourselves
because of the record turnout in this
election cycle
now some of us have been so exhausted by
the decade of this administration
that it has felt a little bit more like
a relief to get rid of donald trump
than the celebration that it should be
but the reality
is that for better or for worse this
trump era has brought out
and inspired people to engage in the
process and that's huge so
you know thank you for continuing to
remind us that more americans turned out
for this election and then certainly the
democrats joe biden got more votes than
anybody
in the history of presidential elections
um received so that's a very very very
big
deal here's the thing though and i'm not
going to let this go
is that now that we are making history
again
what will they do with it when they
start to govern that's going to be the
question so how does our country change
because of this moment in time
absolutely that's a really good point
jeff do you expect any
ceremonial gestures i feel like you know
to the piece about how republicans are
going to respond to this in terms of
governing
uh more pressingly and in the short term
we
we have to see what the president does
if joe biden does
cross the threshold and claim victory if
he does that
will there be a concession call between
the two what are your sources telling
you in terms of
what the president's plans are if you
know everyone calls it joe biden
is the winner uh and donald trump has to
concede or
will he yeah it's a great question
i spoke to multiple sources today one of
them outlined it
as follows he made a comparison to the
2000 election
uh when of course there was the long
drawn-out battle in florida
between george w bush and al gore
this source made the comparison by
saying you know
then governor bush proceeded as if he
had won
uh started a transition team you know
got himself ready for the white house
and basically
waited uh while al gore
waited until the process was over at the
supreme court and then
and then conceded the the sides and the
hats are different in this one it will
be
democrat joe biden proceeding uh with
the transition
and the current occupant of the oval
office donald trump president trump
waiting to exhaust all legal avenues but
eventually
if indeed the numbers get there and vice
president
biden becomes president-elect they say
that president trump will get there too
well we'll see what happens eugene if
joe biden does come out on the
on top in this election what
demographics would you
credit uh with giving him that potential
win
well obviously it's it appears that uh
in these states that he won
um uh well or that he's leading with
should i say
georgia and pennsylvania um if the urban
cores
uh are places that uh turned out black
voters
uh black women and and black men um who
voted in
rates and percentages that they did not
vote
in 2016. as you recall there were about
4.4 million obama voters from 2012 that
did not vote in 2016
um and about a third of them were black
and so
the the democratic party was very
focused on trying to get those people to
return
uh to the polls uh one thing i think is
really important that people uh may have
glossed over
uh and all of the focus on uh the
turnout in the urban core in georgia
for biden is that georgia is a state
that a lot of democrats
you know don't try to compete that hard
in because it's so red
but in the last few weeks biden would go
to
georgia but he actually went to white
rural areas whereas his surrogates went
like you know obama and kamala went to
us uh to the urban core and so he really
wanted to hit
as many demographics as he could
julia that makes a lot of sense eugene
scott i
well we're yes just very quickly just
one last minute real quick
i just want everybody to remember that
no democratic
uh president has won the majority of the
white vote
like since in since linda b johnson joe
biden
is only getting about 42 percent of the
white vote
barack obama won the first time with
close to 45. so at the end of the day
black people saved america
yet again and i'm expecting this
administration to acknowledge that
well we'll see what happens eugene scott
aisha mills jeff mason
thank you all for being here all great
points of course
all eyes remain on pennsylvania tonight
and joining us now is congresswoman mary
gay scanlan of pennsylvania
congresswoman pennsylvania is a scene of
contrast right now dancing protesters in
the streets in philadelphia which i love
because they're
in cosplay wearing mailbox outfits which
is really cute
um and and they're saying we want all
the votes to be counted and they want to
you know protect the results but
yesterday two armed men from virginia
actually drove to philadelphia and were
arrested after police learned of a
possible threat to the convention center
in philadelphia where that count is
taking place
are you concerned about violence if and
when joe biden is officially declared
the winner
i think when uh president-elect blyden
is declared the winner
that our um that the risk of violence
goes down substantially i mean
it has appeared for four years that
um a lot of the violence that's being
encouraged now is because of the
president's rhetoric
um i think we're going to be in a lot
better place when we have a president
who doesn't encourage that kind of
behavior
i think that's true we definitely don't
want a president that encourages
violent behavior in any way shape or
form today
the mayor of philadelphia said to
president trump
uh you need to put your big boy pants on
and i literally did a spit take
um but i feel like you know his point
was donald trump needs to accept the
results
if he does officially lose and
pennsylvania senator
republican senator pat toomey said he
does not see any evidence of widespread
fraud in the state of pennsylvania
other republican leaders in the country
are sort of helping feed these
conspiracy theories um how should the
democratic party the elected democrats
respond to these claims of voter fraud
well i mean we've been responding to
them for some time the president's been
beating this drum for the past six
months or so ever since he started to
realize that he was not going to be able
to win the election by
fair means um back in the summer the
judiciary committee on which i sit had
uh bill barr before us and at that time
barr had been repeating the president's
completely unsubstantiated allegations
that mail-in ballots particularly in
pennsylvania were somehow
likely to be subject to fraud and he had
to admit
under oath in front of the judiciary
committee this is bill bart
he admitted there's no evidence of that
the president has no evidence of it
they have brought case after case
claiming this
there is no evidence of it even the
heritage society has a paper
saying that you know they've they've
looked at all the evidence and there
really
isn't evidence of substantial voter
fraud this has been something that the
president has been
uh pushing it's a false narrative it is
fake news
and he's been pushing it for four years
and there's just nothing to it
all we can say is you know put up or
shut up and he has nothing
yeah put put up the evidence or or stop
claiming
that there's voter fraud state judges
are dismissing
some of the claims the trump campaign is
bringing in court they're trying to sue
in a lot of different states
do you expect any of these legal
challenges to succeed
no but that's been the story of donald
trump's entire career he brings a lot of
suits he
threatens a lot of legal action but he
very very
rarely succeeds he settles his cases um
he takes you know the slap on the wrist
he tries to bully
and intimidate people and we're just not
having it particularly in pennsylvania
yeah i mean you don't have i don't think
we should be having any of it uh in
terms of frivolous lawsuits if you have
valid ones bring those but if you don't
have evidence i i just think that
it's a corruption of the process it's an
abuse of the process
house democrats had a heated discussion
yesterday i'm i'm sure
you may have been on the call or heard
about what happened
some moderates on the call yesterday
were blaming progressive democrats
saying that maybe
claims of socialism labels of socialism
and defund the police hurt some of the
more moderate
democrats running do what do you make of
that argument do you agree with that or
or not well you know we have a very
broad caucus there are a lot of
different viewpoints
i think that the best thing we've seen
is when people represent their own
districts i mean that's always
the uh best course forward um
it does trouble me that in any way we
buy into
uh the narrative that's being pushed by
trump and his allies
um you know the the democratic party is
not a party of socialism it is not
a party that is seeking to defund the
police we're trying to do the best we
can for the families and the kids and
the communities that we represent
and you know i just don't want to buy
into it um
i i don't think we need any help to
foster the divisions that this president
has shown
that he is only too happy to you know
drive wedges in there with the help of
his russian allies or whomever
um we just can't buy into it and we just
need to
represent our constituents and and move
forward
we agree on the basic values we agree
that healthcare is a right
um you know we may disagree on how to
get there but we agree that that's all
right
we agree that we have to address climate
change and move forward to protect the
environment and rejoin the paris accord
we may have differences about the exact
way to get there
but i think the views are shared and
that's what we need to focus on
congresswoman mary gay scanlon thank you
so much for being here
if president trump's rhetoric over the
last few days is any indication
he won't be leaving the white house
quietly so what happens if he refuses to
accept the results
i'm bringing in a panel of legal experts
to discuss what we can expect over the
next few months i'm back in 90 seconds
foreign
foreign
if you count the legal votes i easily
win
if you count the illegal votes they can
try to
steal the election from us
i'm going to stand with president trump
if a democrat were doing this it'd be
cheered on
and we're not going to let the media
intimidate us into
exploring whether or not this these
contests were fairly ahead
i want you to hear this i want you to
really hear this
if joe biden wins this election
there's going to be some payback
not violence half of this country
will believe that they cheated us out of
this election
the president and his allies continue to
spread outright lies and misinformation
about this election let me be clear
there are no
illegal votes currently being counted
the votes that are being counted
were filled out and mailed in legally
if joe biden has declared the
president-elect it won't be because of
found ballots it will be because people
voted for him so as the walls close in
on president trump
what options does he have left and what
will happen
if he refuses to leave the white house
quietly
joining me now is melissa murray she's a
professor at nyu law school
and corey brett snyder he's a professor
of political science at brown university
and author of the book the oath and the
office corey i want to start with you
how do you think the biden campaign
moves forward
if biden is eventually declared the
president-elect
i think they keep doing exactly what
they're doing which is to say that this
is the
rightfully elected president of the
united states and donald trump doesn't
get to upend the constitution upend the
rule of law
the constitution sets a limit on his
term and when it's up uh joe biden takes
over full stop it's not a question of
conceding it's a question of what
the law says and i think reinforcing
that point that this is about the rule
of law sends a message that this lawless
presidency has come to an end and it's
going to be replaced by one
that is about respect for the
constitution and respect for people's
fundamental rights
i mean they always like to cite the
constitution and say they're
originalists on
on the republican side of the aisle so
maybe they should go and review this
portion
melissa both larry kudlow and senator
mitch mcconnell were asked today about a
possible transfer of power and they both
said it would be peaceful
listen to this of course we've had a
peaceful transfer of power going back to
1792 every four years
you've moved on to a new administration
in 1792 it was the second washington
administration well i think there will
be a peaceful transfer
of power this is a great country this is
the greatest democracy in the world
and we abide by the rule of law and so
will this president
melissa do you think they're right do
you really think the president is going
to give
the kind of transfer of power he
received from president obama
i mean melania gave michelle a tiffany's
box you think
you think any of that is going to happen
here
well i think those are two different
questions i think they're exactly right
there is going to be a peaceful
transition of power whether the
president goes willingly i think is a
different matter so i think
you should note here that we are seeing
rank and file republicans lifelong
politicians
get on board with the constitution the
people who are talking about
resisting wanting to go back and make
sure the president wasn't cheated these
are his base and they're stoking
these continual fears that there's been
some kind of chicanery
with this election the president was
saying this even before ballots were
cast that if anything was mailed in
it would inevitably be fraudulent so
he's been laying a foundation
for this kind of skepticism for a long
time but there is absolutely no proof
that any of these ballots were not
validly cast
like these elections have been going on
the people who are working in election
administration
are taking this incredibly seriously and
so the president can
gnash his teeth and whale about it but
i'm not sure that it's actually going to
get him
what he seeks which is the continued
relevancy of being the president of the
united states
i mean i feel like he thinks he's in an
episode of scandal which we are not
in that that is not real that is not
real um at least i hope not cory you
tweeted that
you don't see a serious legal threat uh
you know in in all of these lawsuits uh
that the president
and his team are filing in a variety of
states i mean preventing a abide in
victory or attempting to what do you
mean by
by that i think the most serious
legal issue might be in pennsylvania
where there's a question
about ballots received after
election day and whether they can be
counted but i listened to the
secretary of state from pennsylvania who
said those ballots aren't going to make
a difference and in fact she's
separating them out
so that to me is the only serious legal
issue the court refused to intervene to
overturn
the so far the pennsylvania supreme
court we allowed the votes to continue
and otherwise i'm seeing just a lot of
nonsense the president is making up
lies about fraud that he has no basis
for
he hasn't shown any evidence and look at
who they're sending out
it's people like rudy giuliani it's it's
really jokesters that we're used to
you know making false claims and they're
backing up the president and his false
claims
thankfully fox news cut away from that
speech because they i think realize that
the jig is up here
and who would think that we would be
praising fox news but ultimately
uh they are coming through and reporting
the facts uh they have the numbers the
actual numbers on the board
and so i think these legal challenges
aren't going anywhere and that joe biden
is going to be the next president of the
united states
i feel like part of it is a public
relations strategy
to say we're filing lawsuits over here
so it's like the trump campaign is
filing legal challenges
melissa do you think part of it is that
it's a pr strategy more than a legal
strategy
when you actually read these uh filings
they're they're pretty light on facts
and law
well well that is generous um it's been
said that if you don't have the law on
your side
pound the facts if you don't have the
facts on your side pound the law
and when you don't have either i guess
you just pound sand which is what's
happening
right now so i don't think that these
are going to be particularly successful
but i do think that there is a pr
strategy being lined up i'm not sure
that it's necessarily about this moment
the president is trying i think to lay a
foundation among his base
that he has been cheated out of
something and that lays the foundation
for him for the next four years
to basically operate as a kind of
president in exile for
this large portion of the country that
he says supports him and they do support
him but
that doesn't mean he was validly elected
and so i think
it is incredibly dangerous to continue
this idea that
he has been cheated somehow that there
is something fraudulent about this
election
we should all take it very seriously
within the media and do our best to
really debunk these notions because we
cannot have
a shadow presidency alongside a validly
elected president
cory in the last minute here uh i guess
my question is is there any
thing in the constitution that helps us
from having a president in exile
that sounds really alarming well i think
there are a couple of things one is the
president
has uh claimed so far that he's immune
from prosecution
while he's in office and there's a
debate about that but the department of
justice does have a policy that says
that sitting presidents can't be
indicted and i think that's a major
reason
why mr mueller did not indict the
president for obstruction of justice
despite
the 10 instances of obstruction outlined
in the report
but once he's gone the constitution is
uh basically a document of law and there
is certainly no immunity
for presidents after they leave office
so i think that there's a good chance
that these investigations
by vance's office in manhattan
by the new york attorney general leticia
james and possibly by the future
attorney general looking into these
charges of obstruction of justice
that the president might be facing those
criminal charges and the idea that
somebody who's
really under indictment and possibly
three areas
uh is going to be a leader of a movement
in exile i think
he's going to be revealed for the fraud
that he is and for
frankly the criminal that he is and once
people see the truth they're not going
to follow this
faker anymore
well at the very least i suppose that
will keep him very busy
um so maybe he won't be able to cause
much chaos
uh from exile melissa murray and corey
brett center thank you so much for being
here it's really helpful
to unpack all of that with you 19 former
u.s attorneys who
who served under republican
administrations penned a letter
denouncing what they called the
president's reckless voter fraud claims
they said they felt compelled to quote
speak out against president trump's
premature
baseless and reckless comments about the
vote in pennsylvania and elsewhere
they also called on the president to
patiently and respectfully
allow the lawful vote counting process
to continue in accordance with the
applicable federal and state laws
and to avoid any further comments or
other actions which can serve
only to undermine our democracy joining
me now is one of those
former u.s attorneys who signed that
letter greg brauer he served during both
the george w
bush and obama administrations and he's
now a partner at the law firm brownstein
hyatt farber and shrek
why did you sign this letter and what
are the takeaways
celina it's great to be with you well i
more than signed it uh one of my
colleagues ken weinstein who served as
the us attorney in the district of
columbia
and later was president bush's homeland
security advisor and i decided that
it was important to uh to get some
support for a statement that
really condemned the president's um
remarks the other night that as we said
in the statement were were off base and
premature and really reckless
and had the tendency and will have the
tendency if he continues to undermine
the rule of law
and the electoral process in in in our
country
and so we we gather up as many of our
former colleagues as we could on short
notice to support us in the statement
and you saw the result it's uh it's
important i think for
republicans to speak out republicans who
have
experience with federal law enforcement
and and who have worked for former
republican presidents
to speak out and really make sure that
the american people understand
this is not a partisan issue but what
the president is doing
is uh awfully uh dangerous uh to our
system of constitutional democracy
and that it just really needs to stop he
needs to let the process play out let
the votes be counted
and accept defeat if that is his
ultimate fate
what are the real world risks as you see
them to what the president
is doing and saying right now
well again it tends to undermine our
system of
of law in this country our system of
elective politics our system of peaceful
transitions
this is the way our system works
presidents
are elected uh presidents have to run
for re-election if they
seek a second term and it's up to the
people to decide
who and in our in our history throughout
our history more than 200 years of
history
pres presidents have always understood
that they may not have always
liked that when they have lost an
election or an attempt at re-election
but they've always understood it
and accepted it and we appear to be on
the verge for the first time in our
history
of an incumbent president refusing to
accept that now ultimately i think he
he will be forced to accept it and he
will be removed perhaps against his will
but for him to express um
the the idea based on nothing on no
evidence that somehow
that this is fraudulent and that there
is cheating going on in various states
it's really unprecedented and dangerous
for our system
yeah i feel like you know what's
possible
from this point on it it is a wide
spectrum so in terms of
your point about him being escorted
against his will
is there a system in place like the law
obviously makes joe biden the president
at a certain time
on january the 20th um and the law
follows does that mean
if the president refuses to leave you
know his
his key card doesn't work and you know
he's officially not the president do
they really come
get him well of course there's no
precedent for that but
i i don't mean to suggest that the
president at the end of the day you know
on january 20th will actually
physically refuse to leave the white
house i think what's going to happen
over the next
a few weeks assuming that the the
results
confirmed that that joe biden and pamela
harris have won this election
is that increasingly republicans
including republican members of congress
those people who really matter to this
process will abandon the president
and and some will actually go over to
the white house and and explain to him
that
look we may have supported you but you
lost uh we snow evidence we see no
evidence of fraud
and so your time is up you have to leave
and he won't like it
he probably won't acknowledge that it
was fair
uh i would suggest that he may not even
attend the inauguration of a president
biden
but he will eventually be grudgingly
at least accepted to the point of
leaving
yeah we do have some breaking news so in
the last minute here
i want to ask you about this latest news
supreme court justice samuel alito
has issued an order tonight in a case in
pennsylvania
we've been following that all week but
it's not what the republicans
wanted it repeats the guidance that all
mailing ballots received after tuesday
must be must be segregated out but it
does not direct them
to stop counting them what's your
reaction to that
that seems to be as i understand it
simply a confirmation of what
the authorities in pennsylvania
indicated that they would do
and so i'm not sure it changes anything
i should add zerlina that i just
received word from my home state of
nevada
where the trump campaign was in federal
court today that the judge in that case
denied the campaign's request for a
preliminary injunction to
stop the voting or affect the vote
counting uh in
in nevada and so yet another a loss for
the campaign
it seems that these these various
efforts at
filing lawsuits are really based upon uh
no real evidence and they're being
dismissed left and right
now as a lawyer i would concede that the
extent these suits are filed they need
to be adjudicated
fairly but at some point when suit after
suit is thrown out
by by judges reviewing them that has to
be a signal to the white house
to the president of the people around
him that look
there's really no path forward here we
just need to accept the final vote again
i have a size final it's not final yet
but whatever the final vote is the
president needs to accept it
and move on
absolutely thank you so much for being
here
we're going to take a quick break and
we're going to be right back in 60
seconds
okay welcome back to peacock's
coverage of the 2020 election black
voters in georgia turned out in record
numbers for this election and they'll be
expected to do it all
over again in january to determine which
senators they'll be sending to congress
tonight joe biden extended his lead
there to just over four thousand votes
the state also single-handedly
determined
the make will single-handedly determine
the makeup of the senate
as both of their senate races head to
runoff in january republican incumbent
david perdue will attempt to fend off
democratic challenger
john ossoff after slipping under
georgia's required 50
benchmark and reverend rafael warnock
will bat a republican incumbent kelly
lafleur
after the two gained the most votes in
the state's
jungle primary and joining me now is
reverend warnock i'm so happy to chat
with you again
uh at the brink of this historic moment
um so
first off joe biden is maintaining his
lead
um and and should he continue to do so
he would be
only the third democrat uh president
democratic president
to win the state in 40 years in more
than 40 years
and should you be victorious in your
race you'd be the state's
first elected democratic senator since
2000
how does that feel oh we're feeling
really good
uh this has been a wonderful
ride for me i'm a first time candidate
and we got in this race january 30th in
the special election
and we as we began to get our message
out to voters
they responded in a powerful way and i'm
grateful that we are
we finished this part of the race in
such a strong position
i intend to keep carrying uh forth my
message around
access to affordable healthcare the
dignity of work and voting
you got the most votes in georgia's
jungle primary
but obviously you know there were two
republicans in that
as well and so they split uh the
republican vote with the race
narrowed to just the two of you do you
feel confident going into january's
runoff that
you will be able to succeed and come out
on top or do you expect it to be a
really challenging
uphill battle well there were more
democrats in the race than that there
were 21 people in my race
and because the names were listed
alphabetically and
my last name begins with the w i was
next to the last person
on the list but my message
broke through and i'm grateful for the
momentum that we're feeling
uh i am uh i i think that the contrast
between me
uh and uh kelly lesler who was appointed
not elected by the people of georgia
could not be stronger she has spent a
just a few short months
in the senate she's wasted no time
helping us to understand why she wanted
to be there in the first place
paid off really well for her she's
profited from the pandemic while
playing it down for voters
meanwhile people in georgia are still
waiting on relief
we haven't seen a covet 19 relief
package obviously in months
the people that i'm talking to all
across the state are concerned about
their health care
they are facing unemployment possible
eviction
and they're wondering who can they send
to washington
that will look out for them i know
somebody i'd like to recommend
and i look forward to putting forth that
message in the campaign
in the last minute here you know we've
we've spent weeks talking about
the record voter turnout in georgia it
was really incredible to see
as early voting kicked off what's your
strategy for engaging voters
uh in the upcoming runoff obviously
you're gonna have to do
almost another sprint to the finish here
yeah we got less than 60 days and so
we're just going to work really hard
we're going to use
every avenue we can to reach voters
i've been moving all across this state
uh uh over the last few weeks
and you know the interesting thing to me
ser lima is that i go into small
towns places where they've lost their
hospital
and they're surprised that someone
running for the senate
is in their town america store to
comfort georgia
i'm surprised that they're surprised i'm
running to be the senator for the whole
state
while to move around the state um but i
i intend to talk to ordinary people
and uh both you know through these the
ways in which we're moving physically
across the state but through all the
various media
and i think we're building momentum
that's going to tip the senate our way
and
and bring the kind of representation
that the people of georgia need in the
u.s senate
reverend raphael warnock thank you so
much again for joining us this evening
you're watching peacock's continuing
coverage of the presidential election
mehdi hassan picks up the coverage after
a short break
good night
[Music]
[Music]
good evening i'm mehdi hassan back with
more of peacock's
continuing special coverage of this 2020
presidential election
pennsylvania has the electoral votes to
put former vice president biden over the
top
nevada and arizona together have the
electoral votes to put
biden in the white house so too with
georgia
and any other state tonight tonight the
waiting
continues as the ballots are still being
counted let's begin by taking a look at
where things stand
in georgia at this hour where the
secretary of state warns
that a recount is likely well it's still
neck and neck a difference of only 4 000
votes with 99
of the vote in still too close to call
in nevada a judge has not granted a
request brought by two
trump supporters to stop ballot counting
saying it's based on little to no
evidence
so the count continues 93 of the vote in
a 22 657 vote lead for joe biden
he's leading in clark county home to las
vegas
63 000 ballots there still have to be
processed
before being counted he has a healthy
lead there with 88
of the vote in in clark county that's
nevada let's turn to arizona
biden's lead is shrinking in arizona
[Music]
but trump is falling short of the margin
he needs to capture the state's 11
electoral votes
we're expecting a new batch of results
from where else maricopa county
within the hour and then there's
pennsylvania there's been a
14-point shift in that rust belt state
from trump
to biden in recent days so far with 102
000 mailing ballots
left to be counted 96 of the vote in
neck and neck 49.5 to 49.2
supreme court justice uh alito has just
issued an order moments before i came on
air
uh in the pennsylvania case uh he's
saying
all of the post tuesday mail-in ballots
must
be must be still kept segregated
but it does not direct officials to stop
counting those votes
keep them segregated he says but do not
stop counting that is not a good
decision
for the gop at least in the short run in
philadelphia
for 24 hours now there has been music
and dancing in the streets for the
ballot counting now underway
a celebration of the democratic process
at work
in the birthplace of american democracy
it's kind of been a
joyous thing to see with so much of the
nation on edge stress eating their way
through this week in alaska and north
carolina though president trump is in
the lead
and and that is unlikely to change we're
looking now at north carolina
but those two states alone will not be
enough to secure
donald trump a second term and yet the
president the sitting president the
current president made it clear today he
intends to keep fighting the results
of this election even if biden should be
projected as the winner
the mayor of philadelphia today was not
dancing over that
no i think what the president needs to
do is frankly put his big boy pants on
he needs to acknowledge the fact that he
lost and he needs to congratulate the
winner
just as jimmy carter did just as george
h.w bush did
and frankly just as al gore did and stop
this and let us move forward as a
country
put your big boy pants on i think
someone should have said that to donald
trump a long time ago
look there is precedent for how someone
is expected to act
after an election defeat and guess what
acting like a petulant toddler isn't it
when mitt romney lost to barack obama in
2012 he called
and conceded this is a photo of
president obama taking that call
today senator romney said trump's false
claims of a rigged corrupt and stolen
election
damages the cause of freedom here and
around
the world the last one-term president
george h.w bush left a letter behind on
the resolute desk
for the successor who defeated him
democrat bill clinton it said that his
success would be the country's success
and bush told clinton quote i am rooting
hard for you
america believes in the peaceful
transition of power
the nation watched as the second
president bush
hugged michelle obama yeah hugged her
before helicoptering away from the
capitol
on the day of the inauguration in 2009
and by the way he reappeared at the
inauguration of donald trump a man who
trashed him practically daily
on the campaign trail to be fair he was
also overheard saying after trump's
speech that day
that was some weird excrement
but you have to wonder will trump turn
up to bidens if indeed biden is
confirmed as the winner will he turn up
to biden's inauguration
look rituals are important symbols
are important the handoff from one
president to another
assures us that in the american
democratic experiment
there will be a peaceful transition of
power
that there is nothing to fear but no
today we had to settle for the biden
campaign telling us
it was prepared to escort donald trump
out of the white house on january 20th
if it comes to that those are fighting
words
we should never forget that none of this
is normal
the law and order president is abusing
the law
and has no interest in order so where
does this end
where does it end joining us now are
charlotte alter national correspondent
for time magazine
and jonathan capehart opinion writer for
the washington post
thank you both for sparing time in the
middle of all this chaos jonathan let me
start with you
you have covered a fair number of
elections uh
young man though you are have we had any
other election in our lifetime
that compares to this one no
and not even 2000 um when the
the we didn't know who the president
would be for more than 30 days the
supreme court got involved
and this and and cut off the the
counting
and george w bush became president of
the united states
the difference between 2000 and now
is that we had two competitors who
revered the constitution
we had um the person who was defeated
then vice president al gore who put
country over party and his personal
ambition to deliver
one of the most stirring speeches he
ever gave
during his own campaign for president
but one that
healed the country that brought the
country together
after a a fraught period
what we have now as you said i think you
caught you said a petulant toddler
that's what we have now in a president
of the united states who took to the
white house press briefing room
yesterday to deliver
abominable words from a sitting
president
and so and so now i don't put anything
past him
i am not surprised by anything that he
does
from here on out at all anything and
everything
anything and everything is possible
anything and everything could happen
but he is going to go
indeed so charlotte what do you think
where does that leave
joe biden what do you think it's like
for him during this waiting game
he won the popular vote by millions by
the biggest margin in in history i think
he's ahead in electoral college votes in
the key remaining states as of tonight
and yet day after day passes without him
being able to come out and declare
victory
it's a weird position to be in
yeah but you know if if you're
there's one thing that you're very good
at and that is
waiting uh joe biden is somebody who
from the very beginning of this campaign
has been
uh has been working from a strategy of
slow and steady wins the race
he is long on patience ready to wait
until every vote has been counted i mean
remember this is a guy who came in
if i'm remembering correctly fourth in
iowa fifth in new hampshire everyone
thought his campaign was
dead and then he and then his strategy
that whole time was
wait until south carolina wait in south
carolina
we've got to count every vote in this
primary process
so if he could make months of the
primary where he was getting really
trashed in the press and everyone
thought he was a
dead man if he could make it through
months of that
he can make it through a couple more
hours of this
yeah jonathan biden's taking the lead
in georgia is a surprise even a shock to
some people
what can democrats learn from what has
happened in georgia
listen to stacy abrams one the second
thing though and to be quite serious
look at what stacy abrams did it's not
that she ran for governor in 2018
lost and then turned her attention to
organizing georgia
she had she had been organizing georgia
since her time
in the state legislature and what the
what the lesson of georgia proves
is you have got to to charlotte's point
about
about vice president biden that applies
to what stacey abrams did in georgia and
that is
identify the problem and then work
continuously uh and determinedly
to change the outcome to change the
environment
and to understand from the outset that
this is not going to happen
in one cycle two cycles three cycles
or maybe even four cycles but if you
keep at it
it will happen if anything the folks in
texas
need to look to georgia and look to what
what stacey abrams did as a way of
solidifying what they did
texas came they came very close but i
think to get it over the finish line
they need to huddle with stacey abrams
and to really
pour through what did what exactly did
she do
technically to help georgia go
from not electing a democratic president
since 92
to being sort of the surprise flip of
this
election yeah
it's a very good point about the lessons
to be learned charlotte trump and some
of his allies of course
don't accept any of these results
they're now baselessly pushing the idea
of quote
illegal votes uh this feels the same as
his
fake news narrative any reporting that
trump doesn't like is fake
any votes that are not for him are
illegal it's not just false
and dangerous uh but you know what kind
of weird precedent does it set and where
does it
how does it serve him as a political
argument in this moment
well it serves him as a political
argument because it's a it's a narrative
ride out of the white house frankly i
mean uh there's been some reporting that
you know that when he does leave the
white house which he will if he loses
this election
um that he that this
could set him up to be sort of a uh
right-wing news media figure maybe even
start something similar like his own
version of fox news
um i i actually do think
it's something this narrative of a
redelete
or fake news uh kind of conspiring to
elect joe biden
um really feeds into the deep and broad
undercurrent of thinking that has
flourished throughout the trump
presidency because he's been
feeding it from the belief of the oval
office
so i think that you know uh even if
donald
trump is not necessary according to the
polls right now doesn't look like he
is likely to be the president next year
we haven't heard the end of him because
he still has
a huge movement of people at his
disposal people who believe him more
than they believe
in a narrative and that is going to be a
huge
undercurrent in our politics for years
to come
i think you're right it is going to be
it is that the consequences are going to
be
around for a long time this is not going
to end anytime soon charlotte alter
thank you so much for your insights
jonathan stick around for a bit longer
if joe biden wins
he will become the 46th president of the
united states at a time of civil unrest
at a time when the pandemic is reaching
historic levels at a time when the
sitting president is claiming
the election is rigged and full of voter
fraud it isn't
and when biden's running mate senator
karma harris could become the first
woman and first woman of color
to become second in line to be leader of
the free world so-called
every presidential election is historic
but this one feels more historic
than most carol anderson joins us now
she's a professor at emory university
and author of the book white rage the
unspoken truth of our racial divide
jonathan capehart is still with us
uh cara let me start with you in terms
of iconic moments in presidential
history
nixon 1968 reagan 1980 barack obama
winning
in 2008 where does this potential moment
potentially biden defeating trump fit in
especially given
the wider context of 2020
this is an absolutely historic election
for
multiple reasons one is
definitely for kamala harris right but
another one is because this nation is so
torn and this election was about which
way
we lost we lost carol they're right in
our first arm so we're going to try and
get her back
uh let me bring in let me bring in
jonathan till then while we try and fix
carol's out
jonathan let me ask you this and i i'm
going to go back to carol in a moment
but
if biden becomes president-elect given
this historic moment given this divided
country
can and it's it's the cliched question
i'm going to throw it at you i think
it's a bit of a cliche but i'm going to
throat you anyway
can he unite the nation can he bring
people together personally
i don't think he can i think the
country's beyond that but what do you
think
um that is the question and i have a lot
of faith in
joe biden to be able to do it i
certainly know that he
will try he will do
his level best to try to stitch this
country
back together i mean during the primary
process he
said a couple times more than a few
times that he viewed himself as a
transitional
figure as someone who is of one
generation who will transition
the country and the party to the next
generation
that person he chose to be his running
mate senator kamala harris is somebody
who is someone who is of the next
generation the next generation of
leadership
who also looks like the rest of the
country
the by 2044 maybe even sooner
this is going to be no no demographic
will have a
demographic majority in this country and
so
i do think joe bi if anyone can do it
joe biden can i think one of the reasons
why he is on the verge of becoming the
46th president of the united states
is because people see in him somebody
who truly believes in this being
believes in country over party believes
in
doing things for other people
and honestly believes in in
his power to bring people together
i see we've got carol back so i would
love to know what she has to say
and just as a plug if you have not read
read her book
yes read her book and let's go back to
carol jonathan and i were left
in a very it was a very it was a very
dramatic moment you said it's the most
historic election because
go right because the nation is really
choosing
which direction it's going to go in when
you think about
uh biden as jonathan was saying he's
talking about
a nation where it's the nation of we the
nation where we help each other
the nation where we show toward each
other
where when you think about what trump is
offering
it is it is a nation of anger it is a
nation of racism
it is a nation of white supremacy it is
a nation
of hatred um and
and that kind of vision
in the midst of the kinds of challenges
that we face
as a nation was going to say a lot about
how we were going to be able to deal
with these challenges like the pandemic
like the the the climate change
like massive structural inequality like
police brutality and state-sanctioned
violence
how do we address these in a nation of
hate
or how do we address these so select
when we're
yes so let me ask you then as a
follow-up you're saying how do we
address these could 2020
end up being the year the u.s is forced
to have a series of reckonings a
reckoning about race and racism
but also a reckoning about democracy in
this country and how
flawed and in some places flimsy it is
how easy it is to disenfranchise people
oh absolutely and i think that that was
part of what was happening actually
this summer i mean when you saw
basically 50
movements out in 50 states it was and
this questioning about
how did we get here and so you see
questions about
the electoral college really now coming
into
to to view you see questions about the
supreme court in the way that it got
packed by by the republicans and mitch
mcconnell
asking the question can we do this how
does a nation
survive when it has this kind of just
basic brazen power grab
how is that a democracy you have the
same kinds of questions about
the senate you know so if you have a
senate
that where the majority are representing
the vast minority of people
then wow so the questioning about
democracy and how we get
better as a democracy i think that is so
on the table and i think that that was
part of the reason why
biden and harris resonated because that
was the combination that could allow
this nation to have that conversation
it's a very good point about the the
resonating but jonathan there's also a
lot of talk about repudiation this
week and how this election wasn't
necessarily a repudiation of trump
that many wanted to see at least at
least not a repudiation by the white
majority do you agree with that
uh yeah that was one of the things
uh the morning after the election that
you know really had me in a very in a
sort of
contemplative state um really
the entirety of of trump's uh term has
had me
in that state because the country that i
thought i knew the country that i
thought i grew up in
elected this guy and then to see
as time went along the numbers of people
who continue to support the guy
despite charlottesville
despite the muslim ban despite
babies in cages on the border who are
still there by the way
and yet they still support him and now
to to wake up the day after the election
and to see
that a majority of white people
actually in some cases in many states
more than in 2016 supported him was very
was very dispiriting but you know in
this time of trump i've spent a lot of
time reading a lot of history
reading a lot of books like carol's
getting a lot of perspective
in understanding and especially this is
what was so important
about reading reading carol's book and
why
what we what we're witnessing in terms
of the white majority
in this country this is part of a cycle
and you know the eight years of obama
was a shock
to the white majority of the country and
as carol
argues in her book that the backlash
led us to trump and it is my hope
back to your your earlier question to me
that joe biden will be a part of
the pendulum swinging back the other way
but it is not going to swing back
quickly because we're looking at
69 million americans
who voted for who voted for president
trump's
re-election we are a divided country
but at least now um with trump
the one positive thing i can point to of
his administration is
he ripped he ripped the covers off
things that have been roiling under the
surface in this country
for generations now the genies out of
the bottle
can't put it back in and we have to talk
about it we have to
i agree with you and a lot of what we're
going to be talking about tonight is the
genie being out of the bottle jonathan
cape heart thank you so much
for your time carol you're sticking
around we appreciate that
uh we'll talk so much more about all of
this so much
more to come we're going to talk about
fishes divisions maybe are they really
divisions in the republican party
as some stand up to the president
belatedly and others of course man the
barricades
and as we go to a break a reminder
it's kovit kovitkova you can't watch
anything else
on november 4th you won't be hearing so
much about it on november 4th you'll
know it's okay now we're going to open
here's what happens november 4th
you won't hear too much about it they'll
probably announce it on november 4th
we're going to open up now
on november 4th you'll hear we're doing
extremely well
on november 4th the day after the
election they're going to open it up
on november 4th you'll hear
it's getting better over 120
000 new covert cases were diagnosed
in the us today a grim single day
record that was last night
a reminder covid is on the rise and the
president has no plan to stop it he is
more focused
on undermining democracy that clip of me
speaking giving the news about the 100
000 plus cases
from last night and we just learned the
united states
broke the record again tonight not a
record
you want to break back after 60 seconds
here on peacock
welcome back to peacock it's important
to remember waiting for ballots to be
counted in a presidential election
is nothing unusual what is very strange
is the presidential effort
to try and stop it to do that trump and
his party are resorting to the same
tactic they always do
fear-mongering for instance republican
state senator jake
corman admits there's no signs of
tampering but he's still stoking
questions
i don't have any evidence of any
misdoing
but for all their actions is leading to
wondering why
they didn't want people watching this
process didn't allow full watchers in
the
into pre-voting uh they didn't allow
them to get close enough to see what was
going on
um and the current voting and the
current
doesn't have any evidence of wrongdoing
full stop right
not quite but if you can keep from
getting caught up in the hype
cooler heads will prevail an official
under georgia's republican secretary of
state
who the president has assailed gave an
update to dispel rumors of widespread
voter fraud in georgia
and just a preemptive question i know
it's going to come up are we seeing any
widespread fraud are we seeing anything
that makes us question the outcome of
the election
we're not seeing widespread
irregularities we're not seeing anything
widespread
we are investigating any credible uh
accusation with any real evidence behind
it
so look there is a lot of energy being
put into scaring people
into believing this election is being
stolen when it's not
and even the guy who was trying to scare
you said there's no evidence of what he
wants you to be scared of
bizarre to talk about this post-game
attempt at voter disenfranchisement
because that's what it really is
let's bring back professor carol
anderson we're also joined by latosha
brown
co-founder of the black voters mata fund
uh latasha let me start with you
we have claims of voter fraud from the
president but as you just heard there
official after official is coming out to
say there is no grounds
for claiming that trump supporters have
showed up to try and stop ballot counts
in multiple places across the country
from voter intimidation at the polls to
voter intimidation
in terms of counting the results the
president seems
bent on disenfranchising voters often
voters of color
absolutely because at his very core he's
a fascist and we have to accept that
that he is a fascist this is the
definition of fascism
the bottom line is in a democracy you're
saying stop
you're telling your your supporters to
stop to do a
a don't count the votes i mean that in
itself is a very
definition of it so once again it's
political theater i think that he's
trying to find a way to buy himself
some time to figure out ways that he can
put distrust in the numbers
um and also i think he's looking for a
way to steal the election he has been
very
open from the beginning i think this has
been a setup we saw this coming for
weeks so we should not be shocked
at his behavior he's been pretty
consistent last four years
it's interesting here you say he's
trying to steal the election it's
classic trump
projection whatever he accuses his
opponents of doing it's often what he's
thinking
or doing at the same time professor
anderson since trump can't get his mobs
to successfully shut down the ballot
counting he and his party are turning to
the courts
nbc's pete williams reported earlier two
republican congressmen have filed
a suit alleging thousands of ineligible
people cast
ballots the latest there is that a
federal judge has shot down that
that suit the supreme court also
rejected republican demands to stop
counts in pennsylvania i wonder in your
view is this about
actually trying to win a legal battle or
is this just laying the political
groundwork
to delegitimize another democratic
presidency
this is absolutely about delegitimizing
uh a democratic presidency but also
delegitimizing democracy
um so what latasha brown said about
um being a fascist being um an
authoritarian
about wanting to have this kind of
dynastic rule
um about wanting to actually rule and
not govern
all of that is about stripping away the
institutions of democracy
and one of those key institutions is the
vote
and he but understand he's building on
decades of work by the republicans to
yale
voter fraud voter fraud voter fraud
they're stealing the election
they're stealing the election and so
what trump is
trump is symptomatic of a larger eel
within the republican party
indeed i think you're right to make that
point about him being symptomatic a lot
of times we get
we miss that point it's a very important
point latasha georgia has been
so reliably red for so long and it seems
to be flipping
on one of the furthest right candidates
this country has ever seen
what role did the black vote play there
and what
happened in georgia can it be replicated
in other parts of the deep south
absolutely i think that when you look at
what happened in georgia what i always
say
is that the south is red until it ain't
right and so fundamentally what i think
happened is you saw a level of
investment
and deep organized i think there were
several factors one i think the fact of
voter suppression of what black voters
experienced in the state of georgia
and 2018 became the fuel that fed this
fire
that we organized deeply in the last two
years there are organizations that have
been doing massive voter registration
have been working together as a
coalition and what you see in georgia
as you see a new south rising you see a
coalition of members of the
out asian-american um uh possessing the
islander population
of african-americans of progressive
whites there's a new coalition that is
formed in the state of georgia
and i think we're seeing the evidence of
that this is what happens when you have
deep organizing
and when you have the ability in an
election like we had this time
for people to who are really upset with
not being able to have their voice heard
what i do believe is they went too far
and this is a backlash for those who
have tried to marginalize our vote
and marginalize our voice
and you mentioned marginalize your vote
and vote your organization has done a
lot of work
at getting people out to vote getting
people registered it's worth pointing
out to viewers because
people don't realize when we talk about
the gap in georgia is down to a few
thousand votes
this is after republicans purged
hundreds of thousands of people from the
georgia electoral rolls
that's why it's down to a few thousand
votes
absolutely just this in october 2019
raffenberger actually dropped
328 000 people from the voting rolls two
of the 200 000 of those 328 000
never should have been dropped many of
them were african-american voters
many of them if they did not know that
they were dropped from the voting rolls
which they should not have been in the
first place
if they did not register re-register by
october 5th they were denied the
opportunity
to vote in this election we have seen an
onslaught a
coordinated concerted effort to
marginalize the voices of black voters
right but just as we did in the 60s just
as we've done
all throughout our history we're on the
vanguard of believing in democracy
we've organized ourselves and what has
made the difference in the state of
georgia
has been black voters and organized
black voting power
uh carol i want to bring you in and ask
you a question about the late
uh john lewis of georgia because there's
a lot of talk about how
donald trump went after late congressman
john lewis he attacked him during his
life
didn't show him the respect he deserved
when he died
and now you're seeing georgia and
atlanta and the home of john lewis
playing a pivotal role
in taking the presidency away from
donald trump perhaps
yeah one of the things i remember john
lewis was my congressman
and i remember the the horrible way
that you know trump tweeted
uh you know go to your drug infested
crime ridden because for for
for trump anything that is black is
crime ridden and drug infested again
probably projection um but what we're
we're seeing was that just like
the way that the 2018 uh gubernatorial
election here in georgia
really ticked folks off it's the same
way
with the massive disrespect that
that that trump showed to congressman
john lewis
showed to his legacy showed he's like oh
i don't know he did something i don't
even know i mean
that kind of dismissiveness just
all of that with the organizing coming
in from fair fight coming in from black
voters matter
coming in from asian americans advancing
justice coming in
from the new georgia project coming in
all of those incredible voices and
organizing
and fueled by a real
sense that another
[Music]
four years of trump may be the last
years of the united states of america
and would put our lives our very lives
at risk in ways that we hadn't seen
since the 1950s
in the deep south and so it was
mobilized
organized and so you saw people standing
in line for
you know 11 hours here in georgia
voter suppression saying i'll vote like
my because my life depends on it
yeah and they've had an impact and those
lines had an impact watching the trump
lead
disappear in georgia over the last three
nights has really been a sight to behold
uh we've been covering it here on
peacock and it's been remarkable carol
anderson and latosha brown thank you so
much for your time and your
insights we appreciate it coming up at
nine o'clock we're expecting to get 65
000 more ballots from maricopa county
that will be
a big deal but first a walk down memory
lane
a walk down a racist white nationalist
memory lane
back with more in 90 seconds
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
with joe biden moving ahead in georgia
pennsylvania and nevada
it's looking like we may really be
nearing the end of the trump presidency
but before we set our sights on a
historic new era in the white house
i can't help feel nostalgic for all the
wonderful moments we've shared with this
president
take a look when mexico
sends its people they're not sending
their best
they're not sending you they're not
sending you
they're sending people that have lots of
problems and they're bringing those
problems with us
they're bringing drugs they're bringing
crime
they're rapists
and you had some very bad people in that
group but you also had people
that were very fine people on both sides
omar has a history of launching
vicious anti-semitic screens
[Applause]
and then i see the disinfectant where it
knocks it out
in a minute one minute and is there a
way we can do something like that
uh by injection inside or
or almost a cleaning because you see it
gets on the lungs and it
does a tremendous number along so it'd
be interesting to check that so that
you're gonna have to use
medical doctors with but it sounds it
sounds interesting to me
do you want to call them what do you
want to call them give me your name give
me a white surprise
and write presents stand back and stand
by
but i'll tell you what i'll tell you
what somebody's got to do something
about antifa and the left
we all know there's much more where that
came from that's just what we have time
for tonight
but if you're not ready to hang up your
maga hat and clear all
trump rallies from your schedule here's
a glimmer of hope
from former acting white house chief of
staff mick mulvaney
i would absolutely expect that the
president to stay involved in politics
and would absolutely put him on the
shortlist of people who are likely to
run in 2024.
trump 2024 go back to
keeping making america great again again
or something still ahead the messaging
malay that republicans are currently
facing
we're back in 60 seconds
[Music]
you could say there are three types of
republicans
there are those that are publicly silent
and privately disgusted
by the president's ongoing efforts to
undermine the results
then there are those who have stood up
publicly your mitt romney types
two republican military veterans were
seething
denver riggleman said stop the bravo
sierra mr president i'll let you figure
out the letters
that stands for and pennsylvania senator
pat toomey acknowledged
the president still has a path to
victory but undermine the president's
argument of widespread voter fraud
i saw the president's speech last night
and it was very hard to watch
the president's allegations of
large-scale fraud and theft of the
election
are just not substantiated is there any
evidence
that i'm aware of that there is
significant large-scale
fraud or malfeasance anywhere in
pennsylvania
absolutely not but there is another wing
of the party that is taking a
much different tack you could argue it's
the biggest wing senator elect tommy
tuberville the former
auburn coach making completely
irrelevant use of a football metaphor uh
twitter threw a flag on that tweet and
then there's these people
yet philadelphia and yet detroit and yet
las vegas
they sit in a darkened room in detroit
they covered up the windows so no one
could look at them
and and it is only the hard democratic
cities where they know what the total is
that they got to get the votes that they
got to try to beat the president and
they don't want anyone watching them it
is outrageous i talked with the
president this afternoon sean and i'll
tell you the president is angry
and i'm angry and the voters ought to be
angry president trump won this election
so everyone who's listening
do not be quiet do not be do not be
silent about this
we cannot allow this to happen before
our very eyes when you unite together
senator ted cruz house minority leader
kevin mccarthy
talking nonsense foe outrage even
so look while democrats hoped a route of
the republicans this week would be the
end of trumpism
it now seems to be baked in trumpism
that is
into the republican party joining me now
is staff writer for the atlantic mckay
coppins
who has written extensively about the
gop and about the trump effect
uh mckay fast forward uh to the end of
december and let's say the trends hold
joe biden is elected
and this president continues to tweet
and undermine the election
what does the gop do next do they cut
him loose at any point
well i think it's going to be
interesting to see because the reality
will be that
by december donald trump i would imagine
will still be the most popular
republican
in the party right he will still be the
single figure with the most supporters
with the most fans
uh the one who has the most influence
and power in the party
uh there will be people you name some of
them and there will be
probably more who once the election is
called will distance themselves from him
uh if only because they're thinking
about their own political futures but
it's also true that uh just as you said
the trump's defeat is not going to be
the end of trumpism and in fact
i think trump's defeat might serve to
radicalize
an element of his base even further and
kind of create
the idea that this was a rigged election
as kind of an article of faith within
the party or at least within the
hardcore
mega crowd indeed
the kind of the new birtherism but much
more dangerous and widespread
we've seen what happens to republicans
like mark sanford or justin amash or
jeff flake who
stand up to the president they tend to
get run out of the party
um what is at stake for others who are
like them
and still in office you mentioned that
trump will still be the most popular
republican with the base but do you
think you'll see
you know senators thinking well actually
i don't need him in my state or in my
race
i don't need him it's it's savvier
clever of me to run away from him and
pretend i never had anything to do with
him
yeah you know if we're looking at it
purely from like a craven political
standpoint
i think that there is a hope
among the kind of establishment
republican crowd
that the allure of trump and his
influence with the base
will start to fade once he is seen as a
loser
right once it becomes clear that he lost
the election
uh once his kind of ranting and raving
starts to look more pathetic
than indignant uh there are going to be
a lot of people on capitol hill a lot of
republicans
who are hoping that they can they can
just
forget him and move away from him
without too much punishment from the
base
i think that'll be true in some states
um but i also think that
there's going to be this other force
that that's taking place within the
party which is that
there will be this kind of uh effort to
memory hole this whole
four-year period right there will be an
effort to
kind of bring about a republican amnesia
where
uh a whole bunch of republicans are
going to start talking about the deficit
they're going to start talking about
alleged uh corruption by the biden
family they're
they're going to kind of hope that they
can wave a magic wand and make the
electorate forget
uh how they behaved and what they
supported over the past four years so
that they can pivot back to timeless
conservative principles and i'm not sure
that it'll work with a lot of voters
yeah i don't think it will anytime soon
not with a big chunk of the country it's
what they tried to do after george w
bush of course remember a lot of them
tried to kind of
disown the bush presidency and the
deficits in the iraq war etc
um what's interesting is don jr
yesterday the president's uh probably
loudest son uh went on twitter and said
where are all the 2024 hopefuls why
aren't they speaking up for my dad for
the president
and immediately they fell into line
nikki nikki haley came out and said
account every legal vote and all the
nonsense to trump nonsense
uh tom cotton the senator came out it's
amazing to me i know you've written
about the trump children but it's
amazing
that this family it's not just that
trump controls the gop
it's it's it's worse than a kind of don
jr used the phrase banana republic
yesterday
it's worse than like the worst failed
states in the developing world
where this family now controls the party
of lincoln and eisenhower
it's it's been remarkable to watch don
jr and eric
go out there and really act like kind of
part of the
a mafia family where they were you know
conducting a shakedown on the republican
party and saying you know
yeah you better get out there and do
what we say or else some bad things are
going to happen to your your no
future career don jr i think
in particular is setting himself up for
a future in the party whether that's a
presidential run
a run for office in some western state
uh i know that i've reported before
that that's been discussed in his
circles that he might run for senate in
a place like montana
um i i think that the the interesting
friction that we're going to see uh in
that whole situation is that
i'm not sure donald trump himself is
going to be ready to hand the torch to
his son he doesn't actually want yes
i was about to ask you that okay i was
about to ask you i'd say mick mulvaney
is saying trump could run again in 2024
so where does that leave the children
you've written about ivanka and don
wanting to run
could all three trumps run in 2024
no i mean this is actually going to be
one of the frustrations
for don jr and ivanka that their dad is
just not going to leave the stage and
frankly this is going to be a
frustration for the republican party too
because the reality is as much as they
hope that they can kind of
let him slink away and and bring about
this amnesia
the reality is he's going to be tweeting
constantly giving interviews constantly
possibly creating his own network
talking about running again for 2024
it is going to be very difficult to
ignore donald trump if you are a
republican over the next few years
i think you put your finger on it and
that's one of the reasons i wanted to
talk to you about all this because
you're right
uh it is going to be very hard and i
think it is the trumpy the trumpy party
now
uh mckay coppin starfighter at the
atlantic uh thank you so much for your
time
and talking donald trump and the gop
with me appreciate it i want to continue
this conversation now and talk
about the democrats and where they are
and what they do next
uh with activist and host of the podcast
undistracted britney patnick cunningham
also with me contributing op-ed writer
for the new york times uh wajahat ali
let's talk about what some are calling
an emerging split it was already a split
but emerging in the wake of this
election
uh in the democratic party um especially
in the wake of uh some of the comments
made this week
let's start with you democrats are
masters in my view of the circular
firing squad
even at a time when they should be
getting ready to celebrate and talk
about the potential
getting back of the presidency with
donald trump you have the recriminations
have already started
about who's to blame for the house uh
who's to blame for the senate which
ideas
um what do you make of all these
recriminations that are going on right
now
yeah democrats are incapable of actually
realizing that they're in the end zone
they've won they have scored the the
clock is done there's no review and they
can just get to spike the ball
uh this is democrats being democrats and
they're always held hostage by the
narrative
constructed by the republicans so
somehow joe biden is going to win 80
million votes he's going to win by more
than 7 million votes he's going to flip
five states
instead of saying yo we won and we're in
a
a structurally disadvantageous system
that does not reward the popular vote
thanks to the electoral college and
gerrymandering and voter suppression
instead
we're going to whine and moan and just
boohoo ourselves and actually
instead of uniting we're going to crush
each other and we're going to go against
the squad and not actually have our
our our people like held together
democrats
need to come up with better messaging
you cannot blame aoc for knowing how to
message
properly for knowing how to use
instagram and for being a progressive
with her base if spanberger and others
want to improve
message better learn instagram learn
twitter start to be passionate and
inspire your base that's my message and
take away
so so it's a nice segue into my next
question which i'll put to you brittany
there was this heated conference call
yesterday uh between house democrats uh
mentioned spanberger congresswoman
abigail spanberger who flipped her
more conservative district in virginia
in 2018 uh
held onto it narrowly this time around
she was furious on the call saying
basically stop talking about socialism
stop talking about defunding the police
although i'm not sure which democrats
you know joe biden wasn't talking about
defunding the police uh and it's cost
you know it's costing them seats she
said uh do you agree with that
number a is our argument correct b is
this the time to be having it
well here's the thing i think that we
have clear evidence
that there are um proposals
and issue areas that are incredibly
important to the american people
whether or not folks who are made
uncomfortable by them want to admit it
this race was decided by people of color
it was decided by some of the most
progressive voters in the entire country
who understood that they needed to use
this election to reduce
harm and create better conditions for
our organizing in the future
administration
that doesn't mean that everyone who
voted for joe biden is
really really excited about all of the
proposals um that he put forth and in
order to truly unite the democratic
party
then we have to actually be the party of
inclusion that we say that we are
we have to actually include all of the
ideas and the folks
who brought this victory home and make
sure that their needs and their concerns
are adequately addressed because the
thing about it is
voters of color young voters
marginalized voters
they are waking up today and will wake
up tomorrow thinking expressly about
just how much power we have
about the power to decide and change the
fate of entire elections
and the democrats will have four years
to really show and prove
that they're ready to invest in those
communities that they're ready to meet
and reward that effort with real policy
and i'm worried about what will happen
to the party in four years if that
doesn't happen
so i actually don't think this is the
time to be poo pooing uh
progressive voters and voters of color
and and what people call identity
politics
i actually think we have to to recognize
the value in those things
and if we're a big ten party open up the
tent
and and you know to your point uh we had
congresswoman rashida taleb who
who kept her seat in michigan and
boosted turnout massively there
uh she was on the show yesterday she was
pushing back pretty hard uh congressman
ocasio-cortez today pushed back very
hard as which art mentioned on twitter
um and then you have mitch mcconnell
which is
which is what amuses me in the midst of
all this there's mitch mcconnell waiting
in the wings to do what he does best
what joe biden is going to face
possibly depending on what happens in
georgia in january
a republican-led senate again uh as
barack obama did for much of his
presidency
he could struggle to appoint his cabinet
uh jeff hauser of revolving door project
uh he was telling the washington post
today look joe biden does not need to
make mitch mcconnell co-president
biden just needs to realize it you and i
wide have talked for many years about
how
republicans bring a rocket launcher to a
gunfight democrats bring a sternly
worded
letter do you think the democrats under
biden are ready to bring their own
their own metaphorical rocket launcher
so i said this earlier today on twitter
and i pissed off a lot of right wingers
i said the following you have to
recognize that the republican party in
its current form
is an extremist minority party that is a
counter-majoritarian party
they will not help you in any way shape
or form mitch mcconnell bragged
to this day that he was an
obstructionist for barack obama
what makes you think that they'll help
joe biden who they've painted into a
radical socialist
joe biden and one thing democrats can
learn is now you have a q a
nut marjorie green taylor an extremist
in the house and guess what the
republicans are always going to close
ranks and
they'll tease her once in a while
they'll push back but they'll close
ranks
so what you have to do is you have to
treat them like the hostile minority
party that they are
i said establish a war room a media
messaging campaign
attack attack attack you got 2022 coming
up that's when you can go full red
wedding
and that's what joe biden has to say
message message message i'm trying to
get you guys covered relief
why mitch mcconnell are you stopping
cover relief i'm trying to spend on
infrastructure why mitch mcconnell are
you trying to stop i'm trying to expand
health care
why mitch mcconnell are you and all the
republicans in the center of the house
trying to stop me
from helping all of you hold on hold on
i get the strategy but is joe biden
gonna do it yes or no it's all very well
saying he should do this do you think he
is gonna do it
he's gonna be sacrificing himself
democrats have to realize the american
people have given them a mandate
80 million votes you've won by about
seven million votes
you can spike the ball you can go you
can be like catholic do the superman
own it that you're a progressive central
people of color give you this election
don't why you can't say you can't say do
the superman anymore because now we know
that donald trump wanted to do the
superman so it's ruined the whole thing
brittany before we run out of time let
me just talk about this senate race the
double senate race coming up in georgia
possibly the
the runoffs right question all this
arguing among house democrats
progressives
moderate to tetra which way is the right
way to go what was the right message
what one is this election
what lessons should pastor raphael
warnock and john ossoff what should they
learn
from this election from this week from
this result as they go into the fight
of their lives come january to build
relationships
and invest in bipoc
organizers door knockers canvassers and
strategists
we know how to get folks out look i've
been a part of a a group of a bunch of
white women
a bunch of black women rather and our
tagline is win with black women
not just because black women are
brilliant on the ticket as we've seen
senator kamala harris be
but also because we know how to turn out
votes we know how to get the message
across and we know how to get people
from
inspired to actually casting a ballot
the lesson here is to invest in the
people who bring it home during the
campaign
and then to make sure that you're
investing in them when you actually make
your way onto the senate floor
they are the the very people who can
help us unlock some of the most
important progressive policies that we
need
and we have to make sure that they
actually are investing in the
communities
that need that the most so that they can
show up for them
maybe can i say one thing five seconds i
love so much
five seconds because we're out of time
five seconds go democrats
stop chasing karen start chasing stacy
abrams stop chasing karen karen didn't
show up for you
that's great okay what i always enjoy
about having you on both of you with
john and brittany is
you don't hold back and that's what i
love talking about with you guys
we're gonna both be back i believe in an
hour's time so we appreciate you coming
back
in an hour in our next hour we'll unpack
the latest numbers from arizona
and i'll be joined by former rnc
chairman michael steele
and philadelphia district attorney larry
krasner as the trump campaign tries to
win in the courts
instead of with ballots back in 90
seconds here on peacock don't go away
so
[Music]
as we hit the top of the hour i'm mehdi
hussain back with more of peacock's
continuing special coverage
of the 2020 presidential election 147
million votes have been counted
and joe biden's popular vote lead is now
more than four
and a half million the path that brought
the biden harris ticket to the verge of
victory tonight
was not smooth for either one of them
harris dropped out of the primaries in
december
before the voting had even started and
this is joe biden's third run for the
presidency
as 2020 began it looked like this
attempt could also fail
biden finished well behind his leading
democratic rivals in iowa and new
hampshire
but america loves nothing more than a
comeback story and south carolina's
black voters
delivered that comeback for him sending
biden on his way to the democratic
presidential nomination
and to where we are tonight and where we
are tonight is expecting another batch
of new results from maricopa county in
arizona
i'd say this is one of the little things
we've come to look forward to every
night
but these ballots have proven to be a
very big thing in the arizona
presidential contest here's how arizona
is looking at this hour
joe biden has a very narrow lead 36
816 votes separate him from donald trump
with 94 percent of the vote in
too close to call according to the nbc
decision desk
in delaware county pennsylvania 20 000
more votes have pushed joe biden's
statewide lead even higher pittsburgh's
allegheny county began counting its
ballots today
that's right began officials say they
also received 1 000 more ballots today
that were postmarked
before election tuesday and they will
count those two
in georgia biden's lead jumped today
after more votes came in from gwinnett
county
in metro atlanta the margin in that
state is so close that officials say
they are planning for a likely
recount 4020 votes that's it that's all
that separates biden from trump now look
donald trump isn't used to losing
he's not used to losing at least he's
not used to losing anything
except money he's lost a lot of money he
doesn't know how to lose
gracefully either this guy was a bad
winner in 2016
and he made it clear today that he
intends to keep fighting
even as the numbers are increasingly not
on his side
much was made this afternoon that the
tone of his statement was different
but its message and the actions he took
were very much
the same as ever the republican party is
dispatching legal teams to arizona and
to georgia
and to pennsylvania and to michigan the
republican governor of georgia is
looking for lawyers to make sure the
count is
fair and transparent not in the entire
state
but only in the counties where biden is
leading funny that
in pennsylvania the gop asked the
supreme court to stop the count
of any ballots received after election
day tonight
justice alito a conservative justice
issued an order saying that mail in
ballots received after tuesday
in pennsylvania must be segregated but
he also said
the count should continue disappointing
the gop in the process
it does not matter that the courts have
already begun to dismiss the trump
campaign's existing
lawsuits a judge in michigan today said
one of trump's cases was backed
by hearsay within hearsay
for the president that has told 22 000
lies and counting
hearsay is what passes for evidence
facts
have an alternative and bluster has
gotten him all the way to the oval
office
trump's legal challenges may not have
enough merit to keep him in the white
house
but they can still do a lot of damage as
he clings desperately
to power i'm joined now by jeff
oh we've got some look arizona let me
just bring up arizona for a moment for
our next
guest arizona the
maricopa county vote is in joe biden's
lead in arizona shrinks
to 29 000 vote
so 53 000 between them in maricopa
county 29 000 statewide
still not enough for trump to make up
the difference and take the electoral
college votes from arizona i think 11
votes in arizona
95 of the vote in maricopa still
counting
and still causing headlines so we'll
keep an eye on arizona as the time goes
by this is what we do now every night
every day every
waking moment we check arizona we check
georgia
i'm joined now by jeff mason white house
correspondent for reuters
uh jeff thanks so much for taking time
out of a chaotic week
uh what's the mood inside the white
house as these results like we're seeing
in arizona
trickling hour after hour the road to
victory despite that little bump he got
in arizona just now
is still getting slimmer for trump isn't
it well it's certainly getting slimmer
for trump for president trump no
question about that
however that little sliver of good news
from arizona is definitely something
that they will be watching closely
trump officials have been saying for
days now that they still expect
a good news out of arizona and they were
in
infuriated that uh fox news and ap
ended up calling arizona for vice
president biden so they're watching that
closely
and uh still expecting from their view
that they can pull out a win
and if they do uh then the the narrow
path
that the president still has uh to
getting the 270 electoral college votes
uh gets a little bit of a boost that
doesn't mean that he's got a
nearly as good of a chance as vice
president biden that is clear
uh but it does give them something to
hold on to
and of course arizona this traditionally
red state that i think he expected
to hold on to uh he's narrowed the gap
tonight but he was supposed to get
i think he needed to get something like
59 60 percent out of maricopa's latest
returns he got 54
so still not going as well as he needs
it to go and here's my question to you
jeff this trump
full court press to stop the count is
that some not in arizona but elsewhere
they're happy for it to carry on in
arizona
is that something everybody is on board
with inside the white house
on team trump because in 2000 the
republicans had james baker
this time around they can't really get a
james baker figure they've got david
bossie they've got rudy giuliani
i just wonder how many people are really
on board with this outside of like
trump jared kushner stephen miller rudy
giuliani
sure well i spoke to a bunch of sources
today about that
and broadly i think that there's sort of
there's
mixed emotions about the whole thing
there were people there are republicans
who are
frustrated that the trump campaign
hasn't articulated a more coherent
legal strategy they feel like this the
legal strategy has been sort of
knee-jerk jump at this state jump at
that state
and they were frustrated by that i spoke
to one source a former white house
official who also said
look republicans are waiting for the
evidence of fraud
and election stealing that the president
referred to from the podium at the white
house on thursday night
that said they are also fine to see the
president continue to fight
uh for reasons like what we're seeing in
arizona they don't they don't think it's
time to give up
uh because they still believe that there
are votes out there that could go with
the president's way
so they're not all polishing off their
resumes updating them getting ready for
other jobs quite yet uh jeff if biden is
called the winner
if he does end up being the winner uh we
know that doesn't mean that the
end of we know that this is not the end
for trump he's not going to give up the
fight as you just mentioned
what do you expect his next move is
going to be and do you think
we will ever see you you spent a lot of
time around this president press
conferences on air force one
is this a man who's ever going to give a
concession speech
well that's a great question whether he
will give a concession speech
and also whether he will call or to
receive or make a call to vice president
joe biden
um it's definitely not something that
would come easily to him and he referred
to that actually when he went to his
campaign headquarters on election
day saying that it's easy to win it's
hard to lose it's especially hard for me
he said
so i don't know the answer to that
question i do know that there are people
around him who
though they want him to continue
fighting right now are
not committed to his sort of questioning
of
a peaceful transfer so if it ends up uh
that it's that
vice president biden is a clear winner
and wants the the this current president
has gone
through uh the legal challenges i think
that he probably
will end up conceding in some way
let's see what happens thank you jeff
mason so much for your time
it's been a very busy week in
philadelphia the birthplace of the
american experiment has seen an influx
of protesters lawyers and even gunmen as
officials continue to tally ballots in
the most popular city in pennsylvania
ballots that could decide the presidency
rudy giuliani has been there
threatening lawsuits alleging voter
fraud with no evidence of course it's
rudy giuliani
and on thursday night two virginia men
with a bunch of q and on paraphernalia
were arrested
near the ballot counting operation for
illegally carrying
loaded pistols in the city as tensions
remain high
joining us now is philadelphia district
attorney larry krasner
uh larry thanks so much for coming back
on the show
um can i start by asking you about the
election itself
trump today uh watching fox news and
tweeting that quote
philadelphia yes he misspelled it
has got a rotten history on election
integrity
uh later on before we went there he also
tweeted that legal proceedings are just
beginning and complained that the
pennsylvania governor and supreme court
broke the law
do you have any idea what he's on about
what little suits
he's planning to push through
i almost never have any idea what he's
on about
because he is completely divorced from
truth or fact
and he also is kind of a dope so when
you mix all this together it's quite a
brew
i really don't know what he's talking
about there is no history in
philadelphia of any kind of significant
voter fraud
the notion that we're going to listen to
rudy giuliani use the word fraud and not
watch it boomerang and punch him back in
the face because
i mean we all know what rudy is this
whole thing is it's this bizarre
political theater
where they basically describe themselves
and turn that into an accusation for
everyone else and everything else
pure projection i think you you hit the
nail on the head it's all projection
we're seeing a lot of loud crowds uh
some of them angry some of them actually
having fun and upbeat in philadelphia
you're in charge of law enforcement are
you worried things
might get out of hand as the days go by
as the final results come in
is this something you're worried about
or is it all under control
well the really good news is we had a
very very smooth election day no
intimidation no goofy guys thinking
their gi joe out there
lining up with their you know little
outfits and stuff none of that
it all went very smoothly and what
you're seeing now on the screen is
really typical of most of what's going
on is people dancing in the street
we got elmo out there dancing in the
street who doesn't love that we have
gritty out there dancing
it's a beautiful display of democracy
and everything that's wonderful
and weird about big cities and then on
the other side you have
you know a sort of a morose relatively
small crew of
pro-trump people who are also being
non-violent i mean there's nothing wrong
with this
but we did have a kind of dark moment
last night when a couple guys
drove up from virginia in their hummer
people who purport
to be representing veterans for for
trump
and they figured the only way to go into
the city of philadelphia was with a
gun a handgun on each of them and in the
back of the vehicle was an ar
type rifle with over 160 rounds
there is more to it i know a lot more to
it because i've had an opportunity to
delve into the investigation that
investigation is ongoing
and they do have all kinds of stickers
and the hat and so on
affiliating them with q anon as you know
that is either frightening or foolish
you're never really sure because q anon
is actually a group that believes as a
satanic bunch of people who are
pedophiles and are
are running a sex ring okay i mean
that's what we're dealing with and
sometimes it's in a pizza parlor
that's what we're dealing with here and
that's all like a big laugh and let's
slap
our knee but when they start showing up
with uh you know
guns and when they start to match the
profile of what american domestic terror
has looked like for quite
some time which of course is uh for the
most part
white americans many of whom have a
military training or members of extreme
right-wing
hate groups when you start to see that
it is concerning
so what i can say is this i don't think
anybody should blow it out of proportion
we didn't have 200 humvees coming our
way with
with wackos in them we had one coming
our way
um so far that's what it seems to be so
are we going to see
are we going to see further charges
we are charging them as we speak they're
about to have a
bail hearing in the relatively near
future the next several hours they're
going to be charged with firearms
offenses and
uh also possibly with uh elect an
election crime or two there's some other
minor charges
but it's the kind of case we have to
take very seriously we're going to be
asking the court
to give a bail that will keep them on
ice while we are able to
uh find out more about them and find out
whether this really is what we hope it
is which is uh concerning that foolish
as opposed to concerning but frightening
uh one thing i wanted to ask you about
is uh we've only got time for one more
question but very quickly
you are a reform-minded d.a you were
elected to do criminal justice reform
joe biden could be the next president
he's often associated with the crime
bill
with mass incarceration although his
platform this time round
is much more progressive do you have
faith that you can work with him on
criminal justice reform
you know in philly we figured out that
you don't spike the ball before you're
in the end zone
i'll be happy to provide any support to
anyone who wants to talk about criminal
justice's reform but i hope they'll
remember that
george gascon right now is winning as a
progressive candidate in the biggest
criminal justice jurisdiction in the
united states people want reform
joe wants to work for the people i'm
sure we can figure something out
hope so too district attorney larry
krasner thank you so much for your time
to talk more about the president's
lawsuits over voting and what happens
when they don't work
and to talk more about the president's
bizarre approach to pretty much
everything
i'm joined by lincoln project advisor
michael steele former chair of the
republican national committee
and bloomberg opinion senior columnist
tim o'brien
also author of the book trump nation uh
gentlemen thank you both for joining me
uh michael let me kick off with you
trump is doing everything he can
to pull the plug on even getting a
proper result
republicans are doing a full court press
on the narrative that there is
evidence we can't just show it to you
here's actually one of your successes
as rnc chair the current rnc chair
pushing that line have a listen
you said that uh at the beginning that
you would be laying out specific
and you haven't heard me yet so i yeah
yeah i do have some specifics i was told
to hold off on sharing those but i do
have some specifics
and we're gonna we're gonna wait until
the attorneys look at it
but the specifics we have in georgia are
very serious
again i'm not gonna run and rush to
judgment and push push allegations out
until we vet them first
i do have evidence i just can't tell you
what it is that is what the chair
of the republican party is reduced to
now michael
i mean isn't that what the whole press
conference thing was was pushing out
allegations
oh my gosh they've got nothing they've
got nothing
the courts have already shown they've
got nothing to the extent that they've
gotten stuff
stuff in front of the courts the reality
of it is this is being done because
trump wants it to be done
he's the the the puppet master behind
the legal machinations that are
ongoing he's the puppet master behind
the rnc
chairwoman uh going out there and saying
stuff that i know ronna well enough no
she would ordinarily not be going out
there saying
um but that's her job and her boss tells
her that's what she's got to do
that's why she can't share allegations
you know
yet but the reality of it is the numbers
are the numbers
this is a this is not you know a
political problem anymore
it's a math problem
no you're right you're right about that
and i'm not sure how strong donald
trump's mouth is to be honest
uh tim you wrote an article today that
says all of trump's lawsuits
are just an attempt to find a scapegoat
for his own looming defeat quote
his true goal is to find someone or
something that he can blame
for his own failures and shortcomings in
this current case possibly losing a
presidential
uh election it seems he can't accept he
was defeated fairly but if he finds a
good enough excuse
will he allow himself to believe he lost
at all is this our way is this his way
out
in a way
he is crafting an excuse he's building a
rationale that he will use
months and and years hence to say he did
not lose the 2020 election
it was a rigged and dirty election and
it was stolen from him
and he's been doing this by the way for
decades donald trump has been party to
over 3 500
lawsuits over the last three decades one
of his old
tricks is to sue someone who has an
upper hand
to then walk away from the mess settle
and say this wasn't my fault i didn't
fail
i have no responsibility for this i
always win
and the reality is donald trump is going
to come out on the other side of this
tabulation a loser
he is going to be a one-term president
who was impeached
and rejected by voters because he was
inadequate
but he will probably have a tombstone
that says i won
because that's how he needs to go off
into the sunset but we shouldn't i i
think we shouldn't take these lawsuits
as anything other than the party's
lawyers
and the party apparatus giving him one
last
nod and unfortunately succumbing to his
own needs
uh but it's it's none of this stuff has
merit
tim you you mentioned all the lawsuits
let me just say you've been the target
of a frivolous trump lawsuit yourself
personally
and now you've got the gop trying to
bankroll his legal challenges to the
tune i believe of 60 million dollars
what was the experience like for you
battling trump's legal nonsense
well just one note on the you know the
gop bank rolling it and eric is on
twitter
encouraging people to donate to the
election defense fund
i imagine that could wind up like the
trump foundation
and anyone who's giving their money to
the effort to defend
trump's election prospects in coming
days won't see any of that
but it may help trump pay down some of
his debts um
you know my advice to anyone who gets
sued by donald trump is he's a bully i
was in a fortunate position i was at the
new york times
uh i had warner books was my publisher
so i had institutional support
legally that made it easy for me to
battle back
but having said that i think he was
surprised we battled back
he's a classic bully he tends to
tip over as soon as someone stands up to
him and i think
my little piddly suit matters so little
when you compare that to the fact that
donald trump is now trying to erode
public faith in our institutions a
number of them and right now in the
electoral process
and i think it's really important for
the party voters and everyone else
to stand up to the bullying
so on that note let me bring in michael
again and michael let me ask you what i
asked mckay coppins of the atlantic not
long ago
uh when do republicans get tired of
putting up with trump
and finally throw him under the bus will
the gop continue
to let trump be the face uh
the be all and end all of the republican
party even in defeat
i don't think they have much choice in
that at this point uh look they they
they have now a new q anon member in
congress
uh who is all trump who's going head
head-to-head with uh congressman uh
crenshaw
uh because he's you know he's not
fighting hard enough for trump and his
response is you're a member of congress
now
grow up basically you know so that's the
battle to come
this is not this is not going to end
well inside the gop
trump's stain is at this point indelible
uh and like every you know you know
garment that you have that you you know
put that sharpie in your pocket and it
sort of leaks through
you're gonna have to get rid of that
pair of pants and and that's
probably what the gop is gonna have to
wind up doing is excising itself in some
way of all of this
so given your given that's your kind of
prediction your analysis of where the
gop is something i've been meaning to
ask you and rick wilson and others on
the lincoln project
other republicans where do you see your
future then is it now
trying to lobby and work and persuade
and pull a biden administration towards
whatever goals you want or is it to go
back and try and pick up the pieces and
fix your old party
where do you see yourself i think it's a
combination of things
i think one is is you know pushing out
good government reforms and good
government policies
uh we we haven't changed our
philosophical orientation i'm still a
conservative i'm still a republican
i support joe biden and i think joe
biden is the kind of leader
shown that he's shown to be himself to
be as a senator
who's of you know making himself
available to walk
and walk across the aisle and work with
you know folks like me
so that that gives me hope inside the
gop
um that's going to be a different
struggle because that that is
long standing that's 35 years that's
going back to reagan
of decay inside the party as the party
began to fracture in on itself
over what is conservatism and what is
republicanism
and now we've got this trump trump
factor
that changes the entire dynamic and i
think probably pushes both of those
uh to the very edge and so we'll see
what the fight looks like but one way or
the other you know me i'm going to be in
it baby i'm going to be there
[Music]
well i'll be honest with you michael a
lot of lefties are worried that you're
going to be in the fight
they're like what are all these
republicans doing trying to take over
the democratic parties that's why i
wouldn't put that question to you on
their behalf
all right let me let me bring in tim
before we run out of time tim you have
written about the president extensively
you know him better than most reporters
i want to ask you this
take us one last question to you take us
inside his head
it's friday night trump's in the white
house hate watching fox news
that one network that might you know
give him the pres give biden the
presidency before anyone else ironically
what is he thinking right now what is
going through his head
oh i you know i think he's like a
drowning man right now
and and this has been a unique
experience to him because he's
learned um the powers of occupying the
bully pulpit
and having a twitter feed that keeps the
world on edge and
in short order people are going to play
radically less attention to his twitter
feed
and radically less attention to him post
oval office i i do think he's going to
remain a force in public life and in the
party for some time
but it will never i think be what it was
right now and
i think he's very aware of that for
someone who
exists who's essentially a media addict
and it needs the public spy spotlight
to be affirmed and to feel that his own
life is in order
this is a nightmare for him right now
a nightmare for him probably uh the
happiest of days for a lot of his
critics uh which i
assume includes both of you michael
steele and tim o'brien thank you so much
for taking time out appreciate it
we will talk much more about this
historic election
uh when we return and as we go to break
let's look again at
brand new numbers in maricopa county
arizona
uh a new bunch of ballots 70 000 ballots
came in
uh you look at the gap there now it's
50.4 to 47.7
it's gone down to 53 500 between them in
that county
that means statewide with 97 percent of
the vote in
things are getting harder for the
president to close the gap
as much as he needs to in the time left
for him arizona crucial 11 electoral
college votes we will keep an eye on
that
and our coverage continues in 60 seconds
don't go away
[Music]
as we wait for final word on a winner of
the 2020 election
and we are waiting i want to take a
moment to take a look at the historic
nature of joe biden's race and possible
victory regardless of who wins he will
have
broken obama's record for the most votes
ever in a presidential election which
currently stands at roughly
74 million pretty amazing that the
person with the most votes
still can't clearly be declared the
winner thank you electoral college
look if biden does emerge victorious
he'll be the oldest president ever
inaugurated at 78 years old
and the oldest sitting president the
record for that currently held by donald
trump
and ronald reagan it's a moment joe
biden has been waiting
for over 33 years he announced his first
bid for president
in june 1987 a short-lived campaign that
ended three months later with
allegations of plagiarism among other
things he ran again in 2008
did very badly in iowa instead ended up
elected as the vice president
to the nation's first black president
and should the third tar
should the third time be the charm for
him he'll have a decided vice president
who's both
the first woman and first person of
color to hold
that office so we're seeing history in
the making here with a lot of firsts
along with it a lot of reminders that
the system is broken
in many ways joining me now is kianga
yamata taylor assistant professor
of american african american studies at
princeton contributing writer at the new
yorker
thank you so much for coming on i uh was
really looking forward to this
conversation with you because there's so
much to discuss
it's friday four days after the election
joe biden is leading trump by about four
million votes
and yet we're still waiting on a winner
does that say to you that american
politics and the american democratic
system is broken
yes yes thank you for uh
thank you for having me on for these
endless
nights and and long days of constantly
counting these votes
um i think you know that this is
people keep talking about this uh
campaign as uh the fight for our
democracy and you know i think in many
ways that it has
demonstrated the ways that american
democracy
is broken i mean if you consider the uh
the the considerable efforts to
erect obstacles to keep people from
voting to undermine
people's access to vote to counting the
votes republicans
today coming out and suggesting that
pennsylvania just redo the vote because
they don't like the outcome
and this isn't just you know social
media yahoos these are high-ranking
officials up to the president of the
united states making these
uh these kinds of suggestions and i
think that
uh even with the the resilience of
of voters to withstand this particularly
black voters where
these kinds of efforts have largely been
directed
that's not a vindication of uh
american democracy that that is a
testament to the defiance really
of african americans if anything i think
that the the protests
uh that began in the summer uh that that
people's willingness to withstand this
kind of voter harassment
uh is a continuation of those protests
it's not necessarily
inspired uh by the the candidacy
of of joe biden but really is an
affirmation
of uh african-american and other
people's right
uh to to vote in this country
uh yes i'm very well put out and we're
hearing tonight 148 million i believe
uh ballots cast uh in this election a
record turnout
uh this is biden's third run for the
presidency the first where he made it
past the primaries and if you take out
all the noise around the election
uh a biden win was almost predictable he
was a favorite going in
uh yes he bounced back after iowa but he
led trump every single day in the polls
from the day he declared his candidacy
he's now leading it's not a landslide
but he's got a very big
you know popular vote lead um and i'm
just wondering what does that tell you
about the state of the nation um
in terms of you know everyone talked
about polarized nation
how does this result play into the
polarization
well biden i mean biden looks like he's
on the the
the cusp of winning but not in ways that
he or the democratic party imagined even
though he
is tallying quite a significant
toll i think that that demonstrates that
this is really
a mobilization to get rid of uh joe
biden
or to get rid of donald trump because if
you look at some of the
exit polls i think it's something like
67 percent of
biden voters said they were voting
against trump
not necessarily for joe biden compared
to
a vast majority of trump voters who were
voting for
um for donald trump and so i think that
the the problem that joe biden is going
to media immediately run into
um is that it appears that the
republicans will hold on to the senate
the house of representatives has lost
seven people
and so we are looking at a continuation
of the type of gridlock that has
effectively
crippled the u.s congress so that even
in the midst of a generational pandemic
even in the midst of the worst economic
crisis since the great depression
we have a congress that cannot produce
any kind of public assistance to people
as millions of people are pushed into
poverty
millions of people are unemployed
millions of people
have lost their health insurance
millions of people are hungry
in the most powerful country in the
world we have a government
that does not work and it has been like
that since the second
term of the obama administration so this
is
this is a a success for those of us who
wanted to see
donald trump ejected from the office but
it's a failure for those of us who need
government to work to actually be able
to attend
to the multiplying crises in our country
so so on that note today we saw biden
take the lead in pennsylvania and
georgia
and i saw a lot of people on social
media saying thank black women for this
uh but doesn't the democratic party need
to do more than just say
thank you how about investment in some
of those communities of color or even
reparations which is such a radical idea
for a lot of people in the democratic
party shouldn't there be more substance
rather than just a thank you message i
mean there really needs to be more
substance
i think that in all of the kind of
myopia
uh with getting the vote out we often
then
lose in the discussion who the
candidates are
what the political issues are that
involved and really
what's at stake so now we're looking at
yet another situation
where black voters are thanked for
saving the nation
but where there is really no commitment
uh
to understand the responsibility of that
the democratic party wants all of the
votes of
black americans without any of the
obligation or responsibility
uh to actually create policies
that can deal with the disproportionate
ways that inequality
affects black people um in this country
and
to me it represents uh almost a third
crisis
in uh the the u.s democracy which is
the the stranglehold that the two-party
system
has on being able uh to develop
different voices
different choices uh uh a different kind
of politics because really
people african americans other people
who are core constituency
of the democratic party base are voting
out of fear of trump
not as an affirmation of joe biden not
as as enthusiastic supporters of his
politics
so on on that note because we're almost
out of time but i do want to ask you
this question you supported bernie
sanders
during the primaries not joe biden we're
hearing a lot of pushback
against the sanders wing the progressive
wing not just from republicans doing the
election but
since election day we have moderate
democrat centrist democrats saying
oh stop talking about socialism it's
costing us races we went too far to the
left
do you worry that joe biden is going to
hear those voices or do you think
actually
the left can actually get stuff out of
biden can successfully push biden to the
left
the left has to push has the push button
i think that
this is part of an ongoing conflict uh
within the democratic party
who will lead the party and you know
before the votes have even been
counted the conflict has come to the
surface
but for the centrist uh this is insane
the mobilization of activists throughout
the summer and into the fall
are the reason why joe biden is sitting
in the position
uh that that he is and as long as the
congress is going to be
tied up in gridlock you can be assured
that the social movements the activists
the people
who have delivered this election aren't
going anywhere and are going to
continue to press on these demands yep
out of time but thank you so much that
was a fascinating conversation
appreciate it kiana yamata taylor thank
you so much for your time
when we come back crowds grow outside of
the phoenix center where they're
tabulating votes we'll talk about
threats to the people simply trying to
count balance
and by extension the violent threat to
democracy itself
when we come back
the past four years have of course been
far
from a normal presidency in the past
four days
have been far from a normal election
just as donald trump's presidency was
marked by
authoritarianism and bullying and
threats of violence
so too was his attempt to win
re-election this week
in detroit michigan swarms of pro-trump
protesters chanting stop the count
attempted to push their way into a
center where poll workers were counting
up 170 000 ballots in phoenix
a group of armed trump supporters are
back outside the maricopa county
elections office
some chanting count the vote as
officials tried to do just that
under police protection listen to the
clark county registrar in nevada
speaking to reporters on thursday
i can tell you that my wife and my
mother are very concerned for me but
we have security here we have law
enforcement who are protecting us i am
concerned for the safety of my staff
this is supposed to be america in 2020
not the
balkan circa 1992 that's not supposed to
happen here
bipartisan election officials fearing
for their lives surrounded by
mobs with guns but what do you expect
when you have some top republicans
openly brazenly shamelessly
inciting violence ratcheting up the hate
the abuse the threats on thursday steve
bannon
former trump white house chief
strategist was suspended from twitter
but not facebook for calling for the
beheading yes the beheading
of dr anthony fauci and christopher wray
the director of the fbi i kid you not
i'd actually like to go back to the old
times of tutor england
i'd put the heads on pikes right i put
them at the two corners of the white
house as a warning
to federal bureaucrats either get with
the program
or you're gone time to stop playing
games blow it all out but
imagine if a muslim called for the
killing of the fbi chief just imagine
then there's the president's son don jr
here he is on twitter on thursday
calling for quote total war over the
election
and here he is standing next to
republican state representative in
georgia vernon jones last night
when jones said this
this fight is just getting started
we're starting now to see the white of
their eyes and we get ready to start
shooting
start shooting that's what he said
well we may have avoided a possible
shooting situation in philadelphia
yesterday
two men were arrested in the city last
night not far from the convention center
where votes were being tallied
with pistols an ar-15 style rifle
and 160 rounds of ammunition oh and with
a bunch
of q and on stickers on their hummer as
well
luckily as you heard earlier from philly
d.a larry krasner
just a few minutes ago on this show
there's no evidence of any ties to
extremist groups
or a formal terror plot they were
charged with illegal weapons position
and they got a parking ticket too
fortunately election day itself came and
went without any
acts of mass violence or domestic
terrorism or widespread
voter intimidation but look if you think
the
violence and thuggishness of the trump
years ends
with the departure of donald trump from
the white house then you haven't been
paying attention
gun sales in america surged this year
hate groups were emboldened and
empowered by this president
far-right extremists tried to kidnap and
murder a democratic governor
republicans in congress now include
supporters of q and on
which the fbi calls a potential domestic
terror threat
so i have some bad news for you this is
not over
you can't just put this genie of
far-right violence and extremism
back in the bottle especially when one
of the two main political parties in
this country
is feeding it joining me now is
christian picciolini founder of the free
radicals project
uh in a former life he was a member of a
neo-nazi group today he works
to de-radicalize uh such individuals and
groups
uh christian welcome to the show as i
said a moment ago i think it's hard to
put the genie
of extremism domestic extremes and back
in the bottle is that fair to say or am
i overstating the case
well i don't know that the genie was
ever in the bottle i think this is
something we've been dealing with for
you know a couple hundred years that's
not it's not something that we've ever
called by its proper name
nor have we you know really faced and
it's certainly not something that you
know started or ended with
donald trump uh i think what we're
seeing now frankly is just the beginning
of what we will see in the future
because they've now seen a taste
of what it feels like to have you know
the the most
power that they've ever experienced you
know frankly in our lifetimes
and they're gonna come back four years
from now eight years from now uglier
and stronger i think than they've ever
been so i think you're absolutely right
meddy and saying this is
not the end there is no way to put the
genie in the bottle what we need to do
is figure out how to eliminate the genie
we need to figure out how to eliminate
this cancer of extremism that is now
rampant in our society
no exactly right and that's a depressing
scenario that you paint but a very
realistic one
we have not seen the sorts of mass
violence or civil strife that many of us
worried about in the lead up to the
election
but there is a lot of misinformation and
extremism out there
being inflamed by the president what i
wonder is
with the president gone from the scene
will that make it easier to tackle
groups like the proud boys who he gives
kind of marching orders to in a live
presidential debate
or will that make it harder because they
see as some sort of
their hero their leader being robbed
well no i think that having a new
administration will pave the way
for you know fixing some of these
problems as long as the next
administration is fully committed
to focusing on those problems we have
yet had an administration
that that you know fully called out
white supremacy as a terror threat
we have yet to have an administration
that has said we are going to focus on
the survivors and those who are
marginalized by these groups and we are
going to listen to them and empower them
we have yet to have an administration
that is going to
take this on as a challenge and instead
of walking away from it just because
they've won
is going to take it on as their number
one priority
to make sure that equity is available to
everybody in this country so i you know
i really think we have a lot of hard
work
in front of us and to think that this
election is going to be the end of it
uh no i'm sorry but that it's just the
beginning of what we do
so kristen you and i have talked before
about the role that trump
has played in stoking far-right groups
even if trump's gone the republican
party itself
is kind of white nationalist adjacent in
many ways it has extremists in its
elected ranks it now has
a cue and on congresswoman marjorie
taylor greene and we've seen some pretty
incendiary rhetoric come out of other
republican politicians too
is this just the party of extremism now
the party that feeds
uh domestic extremism now well you know
i think for four years
donald trump has shown us exactly who he
is you know he's shown us to be a
misogynist
he's shown us to be a racist and a bigot
and a xenophobe
and four years later we don't have 62
million people voting for him now we
have 70 million people
voting for him uh now granted there's
hope and joe biden has received you know
over four million more votes than donald
trump
but the fact remains we still have 70
million people
after seeing four years of of what
donald trump has done and how he's
marginalized people are still willing to
put that aside and vote for him
so we have a problem we have a very
significant problem and i'm not saying
that
i i completely agree with you on the
numbers i
i agree with you on the numbers but i'm
just asking about the gop itself because
even if we say donald trump leaves he
loses he goes quietly we never hear from
him again which is all very unlikely
do you still have a republican party
where senators members of congress
at the state house level governors are
saying
and doing incendiary things which acts
as
fuel for some of these far-right
movements oh yeah absolutely i think the
republican party has a big problem to
deal with not only are they white
nationalist adjacent
but they are q anon adjacent they're
militia adjacent adjacent and these are
militias that are not pro-american they
are looking to destroy
the democracy that we've built america
on so they've got a lot of cleaning up
to do but i also want to be very clear
the democrats
going forward must be laser focused must
be laser focused on progress
otherwise you know if we just become
complacent and we go back to normal
frankly what normal has been has not
been good enough for most americans so
we need to do
we need to find a way to do better but
the republicans have an absolute problem
they've got
a whole house that is uh you know
that is full of apologizers sympathizers
for donald trump but also
you know even people who are further on
the extreme like human on like marjorie
taylor green and places like georgia
and uh you know i think as a country
we're gonna have to deal with this
together and it's not just a party
that's gonna have to deal with them
christian piccellini i wish we didn't
have to keep having these conversations
and every time we do it seems to be
more depressing and things seem to be
getting worse but thank you so much for
your time we always appreciate your
insights
we are finally at the end of a crazy
week
but not at the end of this election saga
uh wajad ali and brittany patnet
cunningham will be back
to join me and talk about where we go
from here and as we go to break last
night joe biden trailed donald trump in
pennsylvania
not anymore just now he has grown his
lead to 27
130 votes with 96
of the vote in that's because of a slew
of new absentee ballots in
from allegheny county the return board
is still processing
military and overseas ballots kind of
people donald trump doesn't want to vote
apparently
back with more on the election after
this short break
don't go away you're watching peacock
[Music]
remember tuesday i know it feels like
five
years ago but try to think back that's
when it looked like president trump was
on the verge of keeping the white house
as one of his many residences it also
looked like mitch mcconnell would keep
his job as senate majority leader
but that's why you keep on counting the
votes right now the senate is still
split 48-48
and depending on how things play out it
could all come down to georgia
where not one but two senate seats are
up for grabs
and both could go to a runoff back with
me again tonight a contributing op-ed
writer to the new york times would you
have ali
and britney patnick cunningham host of
the podcast uh undistracted
guys good to have you back uh john let
me start with you and brittany i'm gonna
ask you both the same question
uh you can answer it in turn how crazy
has this week been
in terms of all the political weeks
you've ever covered as journalists
activists human beings watch first
uh i'm a son of south asian immigrants
and i'm never allowed to do this so for
once let me flex
i was on your show twice talking to you
and zerina and tuesday night what did i
say maybe
i said have faith be optimistic they're
gonna flip five states i said it
i said they're gonna take georgia i said
just have faith on the runoff
this is not as crazy as 2000 i'm an old
uncle now i just turned 40.
2000 was the dagger in my heart which is
why i had tough thick skin
all of this all you guys complaining you
young bucks you guys weren't around in
2000. that's when we had to wait and
bush won by 537 votes in florida the
supreme court gave it to him 5'4
that's why i'm telling democrats to flex
you have won by most likely 7 million
votes
and by the way when it comes to georgia
can i just say this this is what pelosi
schumer biden have to do they get stacey
abrams on zoom
and they say this stacy what should we
do
tell us exactly what we what to do and
we're going to do it right now and you
can win these seats because
my brother raphael good man he can win
and ossoff he was fired on that last
debate which is probably what gave him
the runoff these are two weak republican
candidates corrupt
tied to trump we can take this yeah
brittany how's this week been to you
compared to previous weeks
i mean i was 16 but i did live through
2000
i was deeply interested i actually think
i remember al gore
calling into thanks for rubbing it in
thanks for rubbing it in
that watch is 40 and i'm 41 and you're
not thanks for rubbing that
on a friend all the reasons just to mess
with you guys a little bit but i did go
down memory lane about 2000 last night
on twitter to educate folks even younger
than all of us
who had no idea what we were talking
about and did not understand why i was
so
vigorously dead set against things like
the electoral college
2000 was the year that cemented it for
me um and so i do remember living
through that i remember the
painstaking saga that that was and i
remember that that was a successful
theft of an election
i do not believe that there will be
another successful theft this time
and that is one of the things that is
giving me a lot of hope i'm with
waj i woke up on election day feeling a
lot of what i call disciplined hope
hope that is informed by data hope that
is steeped in reality
but hope that still believes in the
power of the people and that is what we
saw
at work also to echo wage i think it's
incredibly important
that democrats actually take this win as
a mandate look if we don't spike the
ball
we will make way and make it much easier
for in four years or eight years a much
kinder
gentler dictator to come along and have
donald trump mindsets
but actually have a prime time ready
presentation if democrats do not
vigorously and urgently
separate ourselves from the kind of
politicking the kind behavior
and the kind of policies that the gop
continues to push forward
then we will allow space for somebody
like that to come in
and i want to make sure that i'm a part
of a party or at least associated with
people
who are ready to do the hard work when
it matters
brittany as senator harris gets closer
and closer to the white house
what does hearing vice president elect
carmen harris
mean to you and to watch i'll come to
watch later brittany to you first
i mean it's just i'm honestly still
making sense of it
i think you know i remember never
thinking that i would see a black
president in my lifetime and then
sitting there on that fateful night and
watching uh president obama across 270
and now to see a black and south asian
woman
actually be right in line to enter that
white house that our ancestors built
is an incredibly powerful moment and i
think we have to recognize this is about
more than just representation
representation certainly matters
um watching that video of kamala harris
tell her
uh her her great niece uh that she too
can be president is such a powerful
moment and that's why representation
matters
but we have to remember that kamala
harris had one of the most progressive
records while she was in the senate and
i'm looking forward to making sure that
somebody who has been very intentional
about her own evolution
and who will bring perspective that joe
biden doesn't have will be in the
meetings and having the conversation
where it counts
so i'm excited about the way that she's
making history
walking through those doors but i'm even
more excited for the policy that will
get done
um as we continue to push this white
house
i'm so glad you mentioned policies
because watch uh carmela harris did have
a very progressive voting record in the
senate
some would argue she didn't have that
progressive record as a prosecutor in
california
and john legend who was on the show
monday night on the eve of the election
he's actually campaigning with karma
harris and
he said to me on this show he said look
representation matters diversity matters
but policy matters too and we have to
hold them to account
so i wonder a what does that mean to you
karma harris
half south asian as vice president elect
possibly in the coming days
but also holding to account is important
as well
you can do both look first and foremost
representation
uh quality representation matters first
female vice president
first black and south asian vice
president
daughter of a jamaican and indian
immigrant is gonna be the vice president
to joe biden
and look we do we don't play identity
politics right because you don't see me
and you
may be sitting here saying ajit pai he's
our guy
you know you don't sit there and say
bomb jindal nikki haley you're not
seeing uh britney saying oh candace
owens it's lovely that she has such a
platform no
it's because she is a quality
progressive who has the bona fides now
when it comes to reform
we have every right to hold them
accountable just like we hold joe biden
accountable
for that disastrous vote the crime bill
right but people evolve
people change and joe biden and kamal
are going to come around
and this is what politicians tell all
the people sitting at home let me tell
you how politics works
they always tell you on the deal you got
to make me do it you got to make me do
the right thing that i know what i have
to do because they have elections to win
they got fundraisers right so we have to
organize
we have to push the work is ongoing and
you keep pushing
towards progress and kamal and by the
way have the ears of people on the
ground who know what needs to be done
we have to do the work to push to
message and to make this a more just an
equitable society and kamala
is the person who can help get that done
she gets it she gets it they will evolve
they will reform we have to push them
gently critique them when we have to
because the work is just getting started
ladies and gentlemen
this is a long-term uh goal that we have
to get to and the last thing i'll say
you had christian on talking about white
nationalists
we're dealing with the death march of
white supremacy all around the world
they're playing for all the marbles so
you if you think the work is over
nope spike the ball drink whatever you
got to drink i'm gonna take a chai shot
next day work 2022 2024.
yeah okay we absolutely on that note i'm
gonna have to let you both go we're out
of time on this friday evening
appreciate you both wajad ali brittany
patnick coming in
we're gonna have to leave it there
appreciate your time i hope to have you
back on soon
thanks to you all for watching that does
it for us tonight on peacock
we will see you back here monday perhaps
with a projected presidential winner
maybe
good night
you